Film Courage: Marc, what do you think makes
you different than the thousands of other
screenwriters who came to la during your time
here? What do you think made it different for you?
Marc Scott Zicree, Screenwriter/Author: Well
I think I was very very lucky in the fact that
I was enthusiastic about science fiction
from when I was a small boy and science
fiction unlike a lot of other genres the fans
became the writers and so they had a sense of
wanting to pay it forward so when I noticed that
the same writers were writing for star trek and
outer limits and twilight zone as we're writing
the short stories and books that I was reading
and the novels ray bradbury harlan ellis
and theodore sturgeon richard matheson etc I
could then go to science fiction conventions
when I was a teenager and I sought these
wonderful people out and they became mentors
and friends that that helped enormously and
and also I just had such a passion for writing
I had such a I had a sense of calling from a
very early age and I understood that because
of rod sterling because of so many of these
writers that I admired that you could aim high
you didn't have to blend in you just had to be
clear what you were sharing with the world and ray
bradbury was a mentor of mine for over 10 years
I'd go over to his house once a month for
over 10 years toward the end of his life
and ray always used to say look inward don't
look out for your material look inward and that
doesn't mean that you can't write about things
that are different from your life it just means
that you find your passions and the your true self
inward and then you put that out to the world and
and so I had extremely good teachers in that
way because I think some writers out of fear
feel that they have to imitate others or write
down to their audience I've never felt that I'm
the same as my audience and if I come across an
idea or a story or characters or whatever that
excites me usually my audience will be excited
too by what I'm doing and I trust my audience
I don't I they're they're I feel I'm with my
family when when I'm talking to all the weirdos
weirdos are good things yeah
I like weirdos yeah yeah yeah
how did that you could actually get something made
I mean there's a lot of people who love a certain
genre but they dabble in it or they're on the
sort of the outside the outer limits so to speak
how did though that you could get something made
and eventually be successful at it well I didn't
I didn't have a in terms of knowing that I would
be successful I didn't know that it was there are
basically two people who are responsible for my
career more than anyone which is my wife elaine
who I met when I was 20. we got married when I was
21 now we've been together 45 years and married 44
and we write and produce and direct together
and my friend michael reeves who was writing
for television and brought me into animation when
I was like 22 23 years old so I started by knowing
by the time I got out of art school my degrees
in painting sculpture and graphic arts from ucla
and because I always knew I was going to be an
artist or a writer but by the time I went through
college and then went to the clarion writers
workshop and sold my first short story I knew
I was going to be a writer and so I thought well
how do you learn how to be a writer in television
and there was really no there was no graduate
school in that at the time we're talking the late
70s and so I thought well I'll write a book about
one of the greatest television shows ever made
to learn how to make great television and so
that's why what gave me the idea to do the
twilight zone companion it was two years after rod
serling's death and had rod not died prematurely
terribly sadly at age 50. I wouldn't have embarked
upon that book because if anyone should have
written a book about the twilight zone it would
have been rod but since he wasn't with us anymore
I thought well let me follow this and see where it
leads now elaine was invaluable because I started
writing the book interviewing over 100 people
who had worked on the show and it started getting
rejected when I started submitting it it was
rejected by 25 publishers over a two year period
and probably if I would if I'd been left to my own
devices I would have probably quit and elaine said
no no just keep going and but we also looked at
what wasn't working which was the agent I had
wasn't the right agent she wasn't she wasn't
seeing opportunity to close the deal and so we
I switched agents to someone who was young and
hungry and she sold it almost immediately to one
of the publishers who already rejected it but
a different editor who had grown up with the
twilight zone and understood why people would
want to read about that and and the other thing
I think that was responsible for my success was
sometimes people are so dogged about this is all
I'll do like I mean elaine and I have mentored a
lot of people and one person they said well I'm
I want to act in a steven spielberg movie and we
said well there's a lot of other things being cast
you could you could try for other things no no
steven's it's got to be stephen spielberg and so
and we said well he might only do one movie every
few years and and it might not have a role that's
right for you you're limiting your possibilities
so I knew I wanted to be in television and I knew
that I wanted to be writing for shows like
star trek but when my friend michael reeves
was writing animation and he said would
you like to come in and collaborate with me
I saw that as that got me into television and then
I could write spec live action features and so
forth and that moved me then into live action tv
shows but that's how I ended up writing for smurfs
and he-man and super friends
and and all those shows and
but I always brought my a-game to everything I
did so I wasn't writing down at all someone once
asked me when I was writing for animation they
said do you write for the child in the audience
and I said no I write for the child and myself
and so I would go to that place that would be
delighted by the jokes or by the stories and then
just write as truthfully as I possibly could and
and that worked and so I've I'm very proud of
the work I did in animation as well as the work
I've done in live action I am here to provide a
service and if I can open a door for someone where
they understand that it's not as hard as people
make it sound that's the trick of it it's like
that's why I wrote green lighting yourself so
people would know that they could be the engine
that drives their career they don't have to give
up power they don't have to wait for the studios
and the networks or the publishing companies even
to see their value because thanks to the internet
thanks the fact we all have cameras in our pockets
thanks to the fact we can edit on on a mac or a pc
there's no reason not to just make the thing you
want to make give it all of your heart and soul
and put it out to the world that's your audience
and that's how you build a body of work you
don't have to wait there's no reason to can you
succeed in hollywood if you're not a workaholic
yes you can succeed in hollywood if you're not a
workaholic but you do have to have a work ethic
and it's interesting in green lighting yourself
in the new book I talk about having a life
and I deliberately put it after the chapter on
building from success and recovering from failure
and I pointed I pointed out in the book that
whether you're succeeding or whether you're
failing it's important to have a life
separate from that because the separate
having people who love you family friends
travel doing things separate from the work
it gives you a breadth of experience but it
also gives you a life it gives you something
that grounds you because you're not just someone
running after the brass ring and so actually
I know writers who have a very balanced life
between family and the work and I think that's
that's a good idea I don't think one should work
all the time because you run out of things to
draw upon creatively but you also run out of I
mean you just go crazy the isolation hollywood
can drive people crazy simply because they get so
materialistic they get so success-oriented driven
that they forget why they got involved in the
first place I've known people who've wanted to
become who wanted to become writers because they
wanted to get rich and I've never seen it work
maybe someone has succeeded that but the people
that I've seen succeed are the ones who just love
the work and they love what they're creating and
they are just so grateful for the opportunity and
it's just there's something like for instance I
just came from a studio that I have that's filled
with spaceship sets and and we we're building an
alien spaceship we're building this hospital in
on a state space station and to be just and we're
building eight foot tall creatures and just to be
in that world and be able to share that world with
with everyone is is great but elaine and I try and
stop working in the early evening we work at least
five days a week and sometimes we'll work weekends
but we try not to but we we'll work and then the
evening for an hour or two we'll just relax and
watch a movie or a tv show or something or go for
a walk or we and we have own dogs and dogs force
you to like get off the sofa stop typing go take
them for a walk and and that helps let the air in
a bit you can't I don't think you can be
successful if you don't have a work ethic
and also I think you have to stand by your word
the more you stand by your your word the more you
have a work ethic the more you have at least craft
if not I don't use the word talent much because
I've seen a lot of people who had talent who got
nowhere whereas if you have passion and craft
and a work ethic and and you I mean the reason
people support me in so many ways is because
if I say I'm going to do something I do it and it
doesn't matter if it's easier if it's hard if it's
hard then it's hard it's I'm not going to stop I'm
not going to turn back I have I have work to do I
get on with it and my mantra to myself when things
are difficult is I'm made of iron and nothing will
stop me and there are times for instance when
I did the star trek episode with george takei
it was a very grueling shoot and and I said I'm
made of iron and nothing will stop me and I had
to use that but we got to the finish line and that
got nominated for the hugo and the nebula and I'm
very very proud of that episode still and that
was for christina moses's first tv role we cast
her out of the blue and she's now starring on a
million little things on abc so we saw what her
amazing talent was right from the beginning well
you talked about talent and talent is very long in
this in this town but but what if someone's sort
of the pendulum swings more toward a hedonistic
personality type well I try
not to hang out with jerks
they're gonna be a really nice
hedonist they know but I mean I think
you have to treat your body like a car that
you might own and you want to take care of
it you want to make sure that you aren't burning
the candle at both ends so many people burn out
and drugs alcohol self-destructive
behaviors gambling all that I it's just
not sustainable in the long run because it's
just too hard on on your mind and your body
it's I I gravitate toward people who have a family
life most of the people I work with are married
they have many of them have kids I want someone
who's stable I don't want someone where I don't
know if they're going to show up and so I can make
the choice of who I work with and I've been very
lucky in terms of the actors I've worked with
even when I was at the studios and the networks
I never had a crazy person I always had people who
were there to do the job and they appreciated the
fact that I was really putting putting everything
I could on the page and they would get these
scripts they would love what I was writing
because it gave them something to act some
emotional through line and and so quality work
gets you quality actors get you quality composers
it get there's a ripple effect if you're if
you're doing your your best work but you can't
be thinking about oh I've got this party to go to
I've got this no it's I mean that doesn't mean you
can't have fun you can't go on vacation you can't
go water skiing or whatever and but but at the end
of the day you have to be reliable and that means
you have to like look ahead you cannot be such an
impulse monster that it's monday and you
don't know where you're supposed to be so
can't wander the streets but so so that's
yeah but of course in in the new book I talk
about if you if you have thrown together
with someone like that here's how you can
deal with it because I had a friend who was an
actress and she was cast on tv show huge hit show
and the the the star of the show is drinking all
day and being very very abusive to people and very
insulting and she just but she recognized to not
engage to do her work she was there to do her work
and she did it and ironically at the end of the
day the actor came up and said you were great
and so she had succeeded I think often what
we have to do is have our eye on the ball in
terms of what we are there to accomplish it's not
about winning every single battle it's not about
going toe to toe with everyone it's not an
alpha dog contest it's about what am I trying to
accomplish and so if you say okay well I'm here to
write a great script and turn it into a great tv
show or I'm here to give a great performance
whatever it is you have to be clear on it
but obviously the more that you take power the
less you're going to be frustrated by other
people who are not there for the same purpose
so that's why I have my own studio now that's
why I raise money the way I do because it's fun
to be in charge because then they then there's
no one around to I mean if anyone's gonna
wreck it it'll be me but then that's my fault
it's like a failing of whatever but but it's so
it's so cool to work with great people and create
work that that has meaning I just I couldn't be
happier is it possible for writers starting out
today to have the same type of tv writing career
that you had in terms of writers nowadays having
the same kind of career I had no they could they
can't really because television has changed so
so much well when I started out I started writing
in the late 70s and still going strong today I've
been very lucky back then most shows had freelance
slots so in other words for instance when I was a
producer on sliders we had a 22 episode order for
that season and 11 of those would be freelance
slots so every day we were taking pitches from
writers and we knew we'd have to buy 11 scripts
now we might rewrite those extensively because we
knew the show day in and day out in a way that the
freelancers wouldn't necessarily but that might
be that first that person's first sale it might
get them into the industry it gave so many people
chances to get their foot in the door get a start
and and I actually ended up writing for so many
different shows because sometimes I'd be on staff
but other times I'd just be a freelancer coming
in and pitching and so it allowed me also to
write for a number of different shows much more
so than if I was on staff because usually you're
exclusive to that show or you might be able
to write a feature when you're on hiatus but
but on any given year any given day I would be
multitasking I got very very good at multitasking
so I might be well like for instance when I
was a producer on sliders I was writing my own
scripts helping with every phase of the writing
on everyone else's scripts and but I was also I
sold to deep space nine that year and far beyond
the stars I had sold a trilogy to harper collins
so I was starting to write the first novel with
barbara hamblin outlining the second one with maya
bonhoeff and I'd also been hired to write all the
outlines for anamorphs and lay out that show and
write several scripts for that show so friends so
I would get into my office at universal at six in
the morning write an entire outline for anamorphs
and then by ten I'd be done with that I'd have
faxed it to new york and then the sliders guys
would come in and I'd do my sliders job all day
and then on the weekend I might be working on on
the novel so we're on the outline for the deep
space nine episodes so it was it was a great way
to work because how to to to go from one thing to
another to another without losing quality that's
that's the hugely important thing you don't you
don't ever want to be just providing fodder
you don't you don't want to just be writing
my friend frank spotless who created a man in
the high castle and ran the x-files he says
good enough is never good enough and I
agree with that 100 percent he also says
you should every time you should aim for the
bleachers because you might at least get a single
and it's and and I share that view which is give
it your best I mean you should just everything
you've got should go into everything you do and
and if it's not good enough work work harder but
and sometimes you're not going to write the great
american novel or the great american screenplay
one of my friends who's high on calls me quite
often and he said well that episode of whatever
show was forever night or whatever the that show
that was on last week wasn't up to your normal
standard why was that and I said well you know
how like when you're in school and sometimes you
really try your best but you get a b on a test or
a c plus or whatever it's sort of like that you
just it just didn't come together and
but that but it wasn't for lack of trying
and so but that's part of it and and all but
but again but in terms of possibilities for the
writers now they're much greater for instance when
I started there were three networks and pbs and so
they had and they were 24 7 stations they weren't
you couldn't watch a show when you wanted to
there was no home video and so there were only
a certain number of shows they could make just
because of the hours in a day so it limited
how many writers could get work and it limited
the what kind of work you could get because if the
show wasn't approved by the network you couldn't
there's nothing you could do and if you wanted to
write something and shoot it on your own it would
cost millions of dollars minimally and and that
was very very difficult to raise that money now
there's over 500 scripted comedy and drama series
on the air on all the networks and vod platforms
and and so there's an enormous amount more
slots for writers additionally even though
there isn't freelance per se there still is
freelance in animation but not in live action
by and large but also people can make their
own web series they can make their own podcasts
there's so many ways to get a following to get
an audience and and and I say to everyone I
wouldn't go back to any other period in my life
I'm i'm happiest of all now because I have such
I have such great autonomy my audience has
given me over two and a half million dollars
to open my own studio and make space command and
and now I'm raising even more money it turned
out I had a knack and so I don't have to ask
permission from anyone I just come up with an idea
I write it I cast it I shoot it I put it out to my
my audience around the world and that doesn't mean
that the studios and networks and vod platforms
can't be my partners they can but they aren't the
deciding factor of what I do in terms of what I
make I'm in terms of creatively and and that's a
pure joy so going back to the 70s and then being
a freelancer yeah completely different as to
the the tone of your day what you're working on
was it well it wasn't so much different that's
what I'm working on because I was always
working on shows that I had a passion for
so whether it was sliders or even friday
the 13th the series which is story edited
I would always find the core of it the emotional
core that would resonate with me it always had to
be something that I could queue into otherwise
I wouldn't write it but and I always worked
with people who I liked and who liked me and I
was very lucky in that when this and the studio
executives and network executives we dealt with
fortunately were very supportive and very smart
and so I didn't find them intrusive there are the
other kind of executives and and you want to try
and avoid those in in green lighting yourself
I have a section on working with stupid people
and my first piece of advice is if you can avoid
it avoid it but if you have to work with someone
who's in the food chain they might be above you
in the food chain here's how you can do it and
not have the work be ruined and not have and not
be fired and so I go into some experiences from
my career where I'm able to walk people through
that and but again it's it wasn't so much content
that was different it was simply it's almost like
there's a difference between performing a play if
you're an actor to an audience versus auditioning
because auditioning you need someone to approve
you in order to do your work creatively whereas
when you're in a play performing for the audience
that's the direct relationship so the more that
I can be in the direct relationship creatively
between the conversations between me and the
world me and my audience the better and and
really what started me on this journey of opening
my own studio and doing crowdfunding and selling
investment shares in space command and so forth
was simply that so many of my friends who were
the greatest writers in television had written
projects that were great and should have become
hit series and the network or the studio cut
them off at script or cut them off at pilot
the audience never saw those great shows I
thought in in books once a novelist is relatively
successful then he can create a body of work like
stephen king for instance or name any writer that
you love and and so they have an authorial voice
and a shape to their career that follows their
enthusiasms and what they want to talk about
at any given time but that's not true with
television writers with television writers for the
most part they are constantly stymied from doing
their the projects they're most enthusiastic about
or the projects that might even be their best work
because the studio and the networks have
different objectives which are primarily
financial objectives and I'm and again they have
a right to do that if they're writing the checks
but now that we can go directly to our audience
and raise money that way the fact that we can
now shoot for so much less because digital
is so much less expensive we can we can
change the rules to into our favor and it used
to be when when young people would like young
directors or writers would say well I'm they're
not letting me get have my dream and I would say
well who's not letting you have your dream they
say well the networks are the studios or whatever
and back when it cost millions of dollars to
make a movie you'd say okay well then that
makes sense they are being stymied but now since
they have a camera in their pocket I don't I don't
accept that excuse anymore someone says they're
not letting me have my dream I'll say you are
you're using an excuse to avoid doing the
work because the work is get a camera get
some people together get the best best
actors you can find make it happen one
way or another make it happen and a great minute
is better than a mediocre two hours of material
but if people love it you'll start to build
your audience that starts to build a career
how did fear of success almost ruin your
screenwriting career and when you hear that
from these these other writers yes do you
hear fear of success in their voice or it's
it's asking for permission I think there's always
a counterweight between fear of success and
fear of failure in everyone's heart in one way or
another in different measures one is always afraid
of exposure one is always afraid of screwing it
up and and ultimately you have to be willing to
face that and get past it and get over it and get
around it your job is to get your work done your
creative work and with all of my mentors whether
it's rod sterling or ray bradbury or guillermo
del toro with whom I wrote a book not long ago I
seek out mentors who are brilliant at what they do
and then one of my key questions always is when
you encounter failure or when you encounter
rejection what do you do and because what I'm
looking for are strategies that I can apply to
my own life in my own career that keep me moving
forward and and it's been incredibly invaluable
because you you find that the higher up someone
goes as a writer or a director or whatever or
an actor their fear is still there but they have
coping mechanisms where the period that they're in
breakdown is shorter and shorter and shorter so
in other words for instance when guillermo del
toro was preparing to film his dream project the
mountains of madness based on an h.p lovecraft
novel they pulled the plug on it universal did
because they thought it'd be too expensive and
r-rated and so forth and and guillermo had other
other irons in the fire and immediately jumped
over the pacific rim and he was off and running
so that didn't mean he didn't feel terrible and
maybe had a weekend of feeling very sorry for
himself but he got into motion and he was already
preparing for that eventuality eventuality in
advance so that he wouldn't be stopped and it's
very important I think don't be afraid of success
because success is very nice when you write a book
or that's successful or a tv show that people
talk about for decades or you get a big payday
those things are fine they're fine I think people
are often afraid of scrutiny they're often afraid
of well I'm a fraud and I won't be able to handle
success but success is an extremely amorphous
thing you first of all you can define what success
means to you for instance at this point in my life
I don't need to have the million dollar payday
I need to keep working creatively and getting my
work out to an audience but money is not at all
what rules me I've made choices we still live in
an apartment we own our two cars outright it's
I've made choices that allow my life to be very
free in that way but but for me success is
very very clear and I'm glad that I've been
successful in I mean I I can look at my career
and say well clearly I've succeeded because I've
created work that people are still talking about
40 years after I did it and also I've earned
significant money writing for the studios and
the networks until space command I'd only written
for the studios and the networks and the major
publishers I'd never done any independent film
projects and then because of this roundtable I
mentor I started hearing about crowdfunding and
I thought well let's see if I can raise money and
turn out I could so even though rod sterling was
considered a dashingly handsome confident
man angry at times maybe do you think he
had a touch of fear of success did he mask
it with the sort of the the this pretty boy
I don't think he was afraid of success he
was extremely charismatic extremely confident
without being arrogant but he felt that he had
failed in his career which is terribly sad the
last interview he gave before he died at age 50 in
in 1975 the interviewer said do you think you've
been successful you do think you've you've written
work that will stand the test of time and he said
that the good writing like fine wine has to age
well with time he said I think my work has been
momentarily adequate which is astonishing and so
sad that he didn't live till now because he would
have seen that he had created one of the greatest
masterpieces of television and he had inspired
an entire generation of showrunners I mean every
major showrunner in drama rod is their hero he's
the idol he's the guy who sort of led the way as
and it's really really sad that he didn't get to
to know that I'm sure he would have been amazed
and extremely gratified sure many other philip k
dick same thing fell okay dick was a different
case because he was at least he got to see
philippe dick at least got to see the footage from
blade runner he knew that somebody was getting
getting what he was doing and so he and he my god
he created a huge amount of work I mean he wrote I
think about 12 novels in a year plus short stories
I mean it's like let's hear from amphetamines so
yes that I think that did help fuel him but
also he had his own what did he call the hovel
which was his sort of grungy little yeah he was
he was a talented man he was very funny he was a
troubled man and there was all this whole thing
of how drugs drove him crazy and at the end he
was raving and and insane and all that stuff
and and I had dinner not long ago with greg
benford who's a fairly conservative professor and
also a science fiction writer and I talked we've
got on the subject philip k dick and he said
oh no phil wasn't like that at all he was
very sweet very funny his mind was perfectly
together and he knew him throughout the latter
years of his life and so I was very glad to hear
that because I think sometimes the media can get
an impression of someone which isn't accurate and
philip k dick was an amazing writer and I'm glad
that that he had friends who really saw who he was
and valued that what do you say to screenwriters
who say it's not their job to get the movie made
it's simply their job to write the script have an
idea and get that out there well I when
people tell me they want to write a script
I say to them do you want to write a script or
do you want to make a movie because they're two
very different things and early in my career
I was friends with charles jaffe who was woody
allen's agent and then his producer and I
said charlie and film and tv wears the power
he said in television it's the writer producer
hyphenate ideally the writer executive producer
hyphen at the show runner in films it's generally
the writer director hyphenate sometimes a producer
but often the writer director and and that told
me where to go in my career I went into television
because writers run television and so that meant
that what I wrote would get made what I wrote
would get on the screen I'd say 90 95 of what
I've written has been shot and my friends who
are screenwriters have lives of endlessly writing
scripts for these other people who may or may not
be unstable but most of their work doesn't get
made and that I know the screenwriters have worked
for decades and none of they've earned a good
living and none of their work has gotten shot for
me that would be a useless life because my goal
is to create a body of work that moves an audience
that entertains an audience that is meaningful
to them and so you have to know what what you're
trying to accomplish so if a screenwriter wants
to be a screenwriter doesn't want to be a director
doesn't want to be a producer then yes they can
write scripts but those scripts may not sell or if
they sell they may not get made the way you wanted
them to get made or you may get fired or they
may be they may sell and be and never get made so
yeah if your goal is to make a living as a writer
there are a lot of different ways to do that or
as an actor or as a director as a producer but the
more you say let's chart a path that gets my work
made and gets me an income then that's a strategy
that allows you to be much more effective and
and I'm not saying not to have a career as a
screenwriter I have friends who've made millions
and millions of dollars as screenwriters and
they've had some great films made but you're
a little more thrown to the the winds of fate
in that direction so so one thing I would say
to anybody who wants to be a screenwriter is
get get mentors who are successful screenwriters
because you must know what the rules are because
they don't tell you what the rules are generally
and unless what the rules are unless the secret
language you will endlessly be frustrated
and the secret language we all learn it
because in order to be successful you have to
know what like when you're in a room pitching
you have to be able to read the room and it's it's
very funny because I once ilene and I once went in
and pitched something with someone who wasn't
fair fairly new to the business and at the end
of the meeting he came out saying well why didn't
you say this and this and this and I said because
we were saying it but just not in words we knew
the person I was pitching to knew that was under
everything we were saying and and and you also
know what's a yes what to know where you have
enthusiasm where you don't there's there's a lot
of ways to read that stuff and and many of the
lessons many people are very frustrated because
they think they're succeeding when they're not
because people in hollywood will act like they're
enthusiastic they'll love your script they'll love
your idea and then suddenly they seem to blow
a hot and cold and it's because a lot of people
want to be liked but the moment you're out of
their sight they forget about you and it's on to
the next thing and so you can never trust their
word and so again that's why you don't want to
a lot of people think that well they
read the script they really liked it
that's meaningless it's like did they buy it no
but they want me to come in again and pitch again
okay well that's not bad but again it's sort of
like they really liked it but they didn't buy it
or they they when you go on on audition and they
say well that was great but thanks but if they
bring you back yes then you are making an impact
we have to really look at what a cause and effect
because there are a lot of things that people
feel are symbolic victories that are actually
not moving them forward and a real victory is
when something gets sold when something gets made
once and when they hire you to do the next
one it's you can build upon success if
you're consistently not succeeding then you really
have to look at what's not working and find out
why it's not working but again you need
to have people who will tell you the truth
but be supportive no one has a right to say to
anybody you'll never make it no one has the right
to say to anybody you don't have ability you're
not you're not good enough these are irrelevancies
the people who succeed in this business
are the ones who are incredibly persistent
my friend nicholas meyer who directed wrath of
khan he said the key to success in hollywood is
persistence with charm because you need the
persistence to get where you're going and
the charm means that they won't get pissed off at
you but but again I know so many people who think
it's like well I've written 10 scripts and none
of them have sold well you might try something
that I mean again if like often people come to
my round table and they've made like 10 shorts
or 15 shorts and I say to them stop making shorts
make a feature because you can't you can't really
make a living doing shorts as far as I know but if
you take several shorts and link them thematically
that can be put together into a feature so you can
do an ensemble film made up of shorts if they're
linked by a character or a theme or or any number
of things or a location and so start thinking that
way because if a feature is too big to do in one
gulp you might over a course of a year be able to
make three or four shorts put them together as a
feature and then you're good to go and so I think
one really has to look at where one's headed and I
think the keys to succeeding are you have to write
from the heart learn your craft so that means
either that doesn't mean go to go to college
necessarily in screenwriting but it does mean
read scripts see why they work see what works
and what doesn't be in writer's groups where
you get feedback but it has to be supportive
that doesn't mean it's not critical but
there's a lot of toxicity you don't want
toxic notes because they don't help you they just
put scars on your heart and find mentors who who
whose work you love who have and who are authentic
because again as I've said before there are two
hollywoods there's a hollywood of creepy horrible
people and then there's a hollywood of people who
are doing the work they love they stand by their
word they're good family people and and they're
good friends to and they're they're authentic and
that's the hollywood you want to be part of that's
the hollywood you yourself want to represent you
do not have to become a slime ball to make it
in hollywood that is there are many many bad
habits that people have you do not have to a
become something you loathe and b I strongly urge
people to avoid working with people they loathe
you will not just have one chance I mean if
you're if you really put your heart and soul and
a work ethic into the into pursuing this you'll
find opportunities you'll make opportunities
you don't have to be the at the whim of someone
crazy and nor should you be and but you also have
to decide from the beginning if you need to be
rich because if you need to be a millionaire
then yes the studios and the networks
are are the the road to take if you can
if you don't need to be rich well then there's a
million ways to earn money writing books writing
scripts you can make films that earn some money
earn some money back you can have your own youtube
channel that brings in money from ad revenue you
there's a lot of ways the patreon accounts I mean
I know people who are their art is being supported
by their patreon accounts and it's just you
you you need to talk to people who are succeeding
in the way you want to succeed and say you don't
ask them for help you don't say get me an agent
or or open this door for me or or introduce me to
your friends no you ask advice and and you say how
did you do this or what what when you when this
happened what did what what did you do and and
sometimes they'll give you answers that you can
apply and sometimes they'll give you answers that
you can't apply if you can't apply it then keep
asking the question of different successful people
until you find the answer that you can apply and
and but there's there are many different paths to
success and and it's just man rod sterling used
to say I when he when he would write scripts
he would say is this the truth as I know it
or better yet the truth is I feel it and that's
words of wisdom let's take another scenario and
that is someone's written what they think is
an amazing script it's been purchased and too
many hands got involved and quote messed it up
yes and that happens often in fact I know some
writing team where they wrote a horror script that
they were very proud of and it got went through
all these different writers and they were very
worried about that and finally the writers guild
decided they would have solo writing credit but
then when movie came out it was really terrible
because of all the rewrites and they were blamed
because theirs was the only name on it and so
that's where I say if you're willing to take power
if you're willing to take responsibility if you
say I'm going to write and produce and direct
that doesn't mean you do it alone you're not
a one-man band but it means that you make sure
that what you intended it to be is what it is
because the moment you sell a script then
the moment you sell a script you're at
you're no longer the boss the moment you sell
the script you no longer you no longer have power
whoever bought it has power and so it can be
any number of things anything can happen to it
it's like putting moses in the in the little reed
basket and floating him down the nile it's like
bye kid I mean will you become moses or will you
become pharaoh or will you become like joe who
shines the statues there's you have no power
over that anymore because you floated him away
that's like what people do with scripts and so
when I was a writer on staff a writer producer
story editor one of the things I would say
at the beginning of my job is I would say
my preference is that I not be rewritten by others
I will do as many drafts as it takes but I prefer
that my my work is what gets to the audience and
because I was a hard worker and a good writer my
bosses honored that it was very rare that I would
get rewritten and so it's you you work harder
but you have less sleepless nights so but again
it's it's so easy to shoot stuff now it's so
I mean everywhere I turn I see people
shooting short films or what or features or
whatever t web series tv shows it's science
fiction never predicted that we would all
have video cameras in our pockets and there's
so many benefits of that and fear can stop you
laziness can stop you you really have to say to
yourself if I have to work hard it's worth it
because I want I want people to know what
I'm doing I want to share this with the world
it has to be that because otherwise if you're
going to be half-assed about something then go
work at mcdonald's because if the fries are not
the best fries ever made then it's okay but if
you're going to make movies or tv shows then then
step up there's only when you when you encounter
resistance or adversity you can either step back
or you can step up that's it those are the only
two choices and if you step back you'll never know
what would have happened if you would just really
put your shoulder to the wheel so I my career
has been made by hand and I'm very proud of that
so you say with the fans give them kind of what
they want at the heart of the story but then open
the world wider is that sort of like the saying
I know you better than yourself which exactly
because because as I said earlier I'm i'm the
same as my audience so if I'm enthusiastic about
what I'm working on if I find a story that
interests me I'll be able to tell a story I think
that my audience will like I never worry first of
all I never talk down to them I never worry about
what will please them I'm just trying to tell a
story that I think is meaningful that meaningful
from a character standpoint for instance and
I'm always writing about things that I'm either
love or frustrated about or want to
comment on but always it's through the
characters if the characters don't work none of
it works and I'll give you an example I came up
with this idea called the show runners network
where I'm creating six science fiction horror and
fantasy series with six major show runners so it's
rocknell bannon who created farscape and defiance
and seaquest and alien nation and cult he's now ep
on evil another partnership I have on another one
of the shows with mark ferguson hawk ostby who
created inward showrunners on the expanse and
also did iron man and children of men and so and
then one of them is a rod sterling project as well
and so so when I started this project I sat
down and I wrote up 200 ideas for tv shows and
and so every day I'd come up with 10 ideas and
just write them down no censorship at all and
and so then rock rock new bannon and I went down
that list and and we saw what sparked for both
of us and something a pet peeve of mine is now
there are certain kinds of black stereotypes you
can't have on tv or latino stereotypes or
misogynistic things right but older actors
either are playing coming down with cancer
coming down with dementia or the funny grandpa
or the funny grandma and the seniors I know in my
life and the seniors that I I'm one of them now
these are vital involved engaged people
they are not those stereotypes and
so I was very frustrated with that so I came
up with an idea for a show called sweet haven
and ironically I came up with this before the
pandemic and the basic notion is a a bioengineered
disease gets out of hand and kills everyone in
the world under 60. and so the people 60 and above
have to figure out how to keep humanity going when
they can't reproduce and so it's a very fun idea
so rock and I worked up the plot line and elaine
and I wrote the pilot script from the outline that
rock and I had worked up and then we cast it and
it has robert picardo from star trek voyager and
it's got barbara bain from space 1999 and it's got
gates mcfadden from star trek the next generation
and mike harney from orange is the new black and
on and on it's amazing veronica cartwright from
alien and the birds amazing amazing cast and and
and they play these very interesting and active
characters james hong from blade runners in it
in big trouble little in china but they are not
going to be playing with stereotypes they're going
to play be playing fully rounded people in that
world and so we've done two table reads via zoom
and we're gonna shoot in the near future so but
again it's just I was excited about that idea and
the lovely thing when you can raise money is that
you don't have to worry about oh is this something
the networks would buy I don't care frankly
I mean if they buy it great it makes my life
easier it gives me more money to play with but
I don't at this stage of my life I don't
need approval I need I need to be effective
so it's a very different energy the
wonderful thing is as if you've succeeded
as you get older if you have any kernel
of wisdom you stop competing with other
people and you just realize you're here to
find the truest expression of your heart
that you can share with the world and if
people are moved by what you create if they are
made better in some way even entertainment
is not is not something to to dismiss it's
an important thing you've succeeded I
mean every day I'm just trying to be
the best version of myself and be open to I love
collaboration I l the actors are my collaborators
the the designers are my collaborators everyone
and and even today when elaine and I I direct with
elaine because elaine is a better director than I
am and she's an actor's director she was a trained
she was an actress and a director off broadway
and I'm an okay director I'm good visually
but but when elaine and I direct together it's
better it's better the work is better the out the
what comes out is better and but what that allows
me to do for instance today we were looking
at sets and getting ready to shoot some scenes
we're gonna shoot in a few weeks and elaine was
her vision was different from mine in terms
of how many people we have in this scene or
how many extras or and she wanted fewer fewer
tighter on the focus on the scene and so I had
to step back from what I was attached to my way
of doing it my design in my head I see the shots
in my head and say well let's let's let's see
what she has to say let's see what where she's
going with this let's see if it works and that's a
good healthy creative instinct because it lets in
the possibility of something better
and and because I'm not threatened
at all just grateful I can do that
and so when you stop trying to be
there's you're not in a race you're not
trying to to beat anybody else you are just
telling a story you are just sharing something
that you love with other people and I was thinking
about an interesting analogy yesterday where I
heard someone talking about quilting they made a
quilt for survivors of the people who died in 9 11
in the family and and I thought it's funny no one
ever talks about pitching a quilt you don't go and
meet with a whole bunch of executives and say hey
I have an idea for a quilt and you spend years
just telling the idea of what you have the idea
you have for a quilt and you never actually make a
quilt people would think you were out of your mind
right the point of quilting is to make quilts
and share them with others but writers in in tv
and film they think that that's an appropriate
way to spend their their lives to endlessly be
pitching and well I pitched this and it didn't
sell and I pitched that and it didn't sell
it's like why don't you just make it make the
thing get get people together make make the work
then you're making the the the the quilt
you're quilting you're not talking about a
quilt someday you may get to make and it's it's
so much more rewarding and it's I'm I'm just
I've got my feet planted on the ground
and and my head in the clouds it's like
elaine keeps keeps my feet on the ground but but
there's such a lovely feeling of accomplishment
when you do something and it comes out the way
you want it and it goes out into the world and
people love it I mean even on mr scifi we put
out the first hour of space command it's been
seen by millions of people and got 97 thumbs
up well that's great it's great to have that
it means that the people really liked it and and
that that helps make me eager for the next day and
eager for the next script were you always this way
where you just wanted to do something that meant
something to you that you were excited by and you
were staying in your own metaphorical lane no no I
was at the beginning of my career I was very I
there was no no certainty that I would make it
and there was always this I mean I was very lucky
because I started working writing my first book
at 21 I sold my first short story at 19 and I
was running for tv by the time I was 22 or 23
and over the next 20 years the longest period in
that entire 20 years that I was out of work was
three months and so I earned millions of dollars
I worked for all the major studios and networks
but but there was always a sense that it could
stop abruptly and it actually did at one point and
I had to figure out a way of reinventing and re a
way of getting things going again and fortunately
I was open to new ways of doing things I was
very open to that and so that's allowed me to
be where I am now but but I was not secure by any
means I was I was driven by a creative vision and
I loved writing other characters I loved writing
whether it was spock kirk mccoy or whether it was
the characters in friday the 13th series or even
the smurfs whomever it was really fun to write
through those characters right write what I wanted
to say through those those characters you have to
be if I can hear the voice of a character I can
write him I have to be able to hear the voice
but but I was never that secure I was never that
certain that everything was just going to cost
along so I never felt like I could just like
take my hands off the wheel going back what I
probably would have done some things differently
my my priority was always I always felt that my
obligation my creative obligation was to my
audience but I often didn't take care of my bosses
as well as I might have I wasn't I wasn't a worker
among workers in a way that I should have been
and it's fortunately I still was able to create
a body of work but if I if I could go back and
change one thing I would be much more taking
care of people in that way and I've never been
a political animal I don't care about those
things and I have worked with people who were
and I've also lost jobs to people who were like
one friend of mine was recommending me to be a
producer on this show that he was creating and the
producer who was running the show didn't hire me
and ultimately found out what he was doing was he
was only hiring people who were his troops so he
could even eventually fire my friend because he
was political animal and and but at the time I
thought well I somehow said something wrong in the
interview no there was no way I was going to get
that job but and my friend ended up out on his ass
and and that's when we realized what it was all
about but but I think I could have taken care of
people better and I don't regret in terms of the
work I don't regret any of the work I've done but
but that's a lesson that would have been good to
have learned sooner yeah some people aren't good
at flying to politics no and I don't like kissing
the ass of people who are mediocre I mean my the
one thing that really I was very open to people's
humanity but I could never stand anyone who just
said well it doesn't have to be great it doesn't
have to be good it's like we're just here to
make sausage I could I could never never never
stand that it's like well you may be but I'm not
I'm here to make something wonderful that'll last
the test of time you either understand the test of
time I I'm I remember one time on sliders we were
someone pitched a clone story and I said to my
boss that story has been done on every other show
every other science fiction show and I started
saying we shouldn't buy it and he said well no
but it hasn't been done on our show and I said
yes but the audience isn't just watching our show
and the irony was that they bought that script and
I had to rewrite it I rewrote and made it as good
as I could and but the thing was it's like had
I been making the choice of what we bought and
what we didn't buy I wouldn't have bought that
because it was cliche already then it was cliche
and I had to fight that cliche when I
rewrote it to find some meaning in it but
but it was a radically different philosophy of
how to make television because I know from my own
experience that a single hour of television can
change someone's life forever for the better it's
a huge responsibility and I never never duck
that responsibility I'm very cognizant of it
why do you like star trek better than star wars
the reason I like star trek better than star wars
there are actually two answers to that I was 10
years old when star trek debuted and that was
the perfect age for me to encounter that amazing
universe I sometimes joke that other people love
heroin I have star trek it was like it was the
thing I'd been waiting for and I just loved it and
it's been hugely influential in my life star wars
on the other hand came out when I was in my early
20s and so if I'd been 13 years old when star
wars came out that would have been my star trek
and but it was just I was just a little too old
for it to engage me in a way that would have
really been hugely meaningful I liked it I thought
it was a very very good film but but also I like
the star trek universe better I think it has a lot
more opportunity for a wide variety of stories I
think it's much more able to comment on issues of
the moment star trek was deliberately written like
twilight zone these were gene roddenberry and rod
sterling were both men who had a lot to say about
race about social issues about war
and and they said it and I think star
wars is much more kind of a escapist entertainment
I think it comes from a very different place
but again it's not for me to bad mouth anything
I'm glad the mandalorian has been successful
I think the more recent star wars films were
problematical because they kind of didn't really
know where they were going and would go two steps
to the left two steps to the right and then walk
into a wall so it was like I feel very sad about
that because it could have been better and I think
there's a problem when people decide that they're
going to go deviate from what's expected and go
in the exact opposite direction because often
it doesn't create good art it just creates
chaos so I think you have to be very careful of
why you're doing making certain creative choices
because they if they don't follow the emotional
line that you're not going to engage in audience
and also an audience that feels a very huge part
of ownership yeah and the story and the characters
and that's and that but the funny thing is
the audience's ownership of something is a
fine line to walk because you don't want to just
give them what they want because then you're just
reiterating the same old story what you want is to
give them emotionally something that's satisfying
but also opens the universe wider does
something that they haven't seen before but in
an emotionally satisfying way so for instance when
I came up with the idea for far beyond the stars
for deep space nine it took us into the world of
1950s science fiction writers which was something
star trek had never done but it showed the
audience where we came from why science fiction
was important why telling your truth is important
and it dealt with race in a very powerful way and
I was very very glad that episode sold and got
made and people are still complimenting me on it
20 years later people often don't know
what they'll love until they see it and so
it's like star wars if if they'd tried to describe
star wars before people saw it I don't think
people would have understood what it was going to
be because it sounded like crap this guy travels
around with this big hairy creature and and then
there's this guy in a mask and he's the villain
and he's it would sound like jesus christ and
I want to be a jedi knight it's like oh god but
but then you see it and what made star wars great
was that it was a visualization of everything we'd
been reading in science fiction for decades but
had never been visualized that well and so that's
what set it apart it wasn't that it was enormously
original it was that it was transferring to film
what had been we'd been reading about forever but
had never seen on film so that was what made it
so exciting flying through the asteroid belt and
all those wonderful things the laser battles and
you name it it was it was great fun it's
one of the most entertaining films ever made
so yeah what do you think the new star wars
trilogy got wrong that's a hard one it wasn't
for lack of trying because I know j.j abrams and I
know he loves star wars and I think he was afraid
of of blowing it but but he certainly put
everything he had into it and he certainly
did a lot of things right I mean the building a
full-size millennium falcon for instance but um
star wars has a very limited bag of tricks it's
like there's the good guys the jedi knights the
bad guys the the new order or or the the whatever
it's like good guys versus bad guys and the bad
guys have a weapon and they're going to blow
something up and it's like it's so difficult and
because you and then mandalorian has expanded that
a bit they put a baby in a baby yoda but it's just
there's so many ways I mean I thought I thought
jj was very clever with his version of star trek
a lot of people are down on that version but I
think he actually did a very good job of bringing
it alive again and finding a way of reinventing it
but with star wars it's like who are those people
who is who is a kylo ren who is I mean he kills
harrison ford we're never going to forgive him for
that I mean it's not like darth vader comes around
at last and saves his son which is a great story
arc it's like kylo ren put the lightsaber through
harrison ford and he fell down and he was dead
it's like you it doesn't go somewhere that you
want it to go I don't care if rey and kylo ren are
drawn to each other I don't know who those people
are and they're like they're like less interesting
versions of the characters that we started with
with luke and leia and han it's like you don't
I mean like poe dameron who is that guy why do
we I mean I like the actors very much I think
the actors generally are extremely good but it's
just where where are you going it and and then
so it basically the first move goes like this
then the second movie goes like that and then
they try and jam it back this way it doesn't
it doesn't flow it doesn't pay off well at all
it's just weak storytelling and but but again
when you view a property as a cash cow then you
just try to get your best people and try and hope
that one out of every three or four will click and
because that keeps the franchise alive and it's a
cynical way of looking at things and certainly not
creative but it's a machine it's factory but that
doesn't mean you can't get great star wars stories
or great star trek stories or any of this stuff
some it's like each time out it's the luck of the
draw it's not that people are trying to create
crap they aren't they're trying to really do a
great job and if it fails it's it fails simply
because what they tried or the direction they
went didn't didn't pay off I think kevin feige's
done a great job with the marvel universe he's
made a lot of great great films I'm not a huge
fan of marvel but I recognize the artistry of
what he's done you need someone at the top of the
food chain who really kind of has a vision whether
that's rod sterling or gene roddenberry whomever
you need that person who kind of keeps it on track
and it's hard to find those people they're very
rare if you were put in charge of the star wars
trilogy how would you have approached
it I would have tried my best to make
it good no I mean here's my real feeling
about star wars in terms of speaking as a
creative artist I think the truly the structure of
the first trilogy is very solid and but the ewoks
by the time you got to return to the jedi george
lucas decided he was making films for children
not broad-based family entertainment in other
words there's an adult there's a certain adult
quality to the first two films that the third film
with the ewoks and all that it's like let's make
some teddy bears let's let's make some products
and then when he went to the prequels he needed
he was writing them he needed a writer
who was solid he needed to bring in a
strong writer because this the basics of the
story the fact that that the best jedi becomes
evil and is and then ultimately rises the occasion
to save his son those first six films that
structure is really interesting but the telling
of it was very poor and so first of all it was
as I say they were films for children and they
were kind of silly but also the writing was really
poor the dialogue was really poor the design stuff
was great my friend ian mckay designed darth maul
but but they did but also when you when you're
thinking of it all as something that's going to
help sell toys then you're not thinking oh
well look here's this great character darth
maul why don't we give him a personality and why
don't we have him continue longer in the show
in the in the series of films he was great
when ray park is fighting two guys off
with with one lightsaber it's astonishing when he
I mean he's great and they cut him in two I would
have had him stuck back together and come on back
it's but but I think there's a lot of weird vibes
in those first three films it's like hey look
you're a 10 year old kid and I'm going to marry
you in the next movie it's like holy cow here's a
babysitter and then you next thing you're in bed
with him it's like what it just gives you a creepy
feeling and and also of course that kid couldn't
really act much and so it's just lost opportunity
what do you love about star trek discovery
doug jones I think is terrific he's the lead in
space command as well or one of our one of our
lead actors and he's absolutely wonderful I think
the production design is pretty amazing I think
the detail on sets and costumes is pretty amazing
the visual effects are good I think it's it's gone
kind of I haven't watched all of the third season
yet but I felt the first couple of seasons were
pretty weak in terms of just characterization and
and storyline I there's there's a lot of talent in
that cast but I would have I would have developed
the characters very differently I would have
gone much deeper I think that there's a very
hit-and-miss quality to a number of the characters
where it's like who are these people and what
what's the point of this story and I think
they're often talking about the emotion without
actually dramatizing the emotion and so I strange
new worlds may be the star trek episode the show
we're all waiting for that's the ones captain pike
the fun part about that is captain pike was
the original captain the first pilot that
gene roddenbee did of star trek in 1964. and
so if that and now that's being greenlit as a
show so it's the longest period for when a show
was pitched when a pilot was made to when they
actually picked up the show it's like 55 years or
60 years that's pretty fun how do you think gene
roddenberry would have felt about star trek today
I think he would be have very mixed feelings I
think he'd be very glad that was still generating
billions of dollars and still popular I think I
don't think he would necessarily be that fond of
star trek discovery or picard simply because they
are missing the opportunity
of telling stories that have
relevance to the current moment I think he
was very very much someone who wanted to
make emotional points that related to the
real world and I think star trek discovery and
picard have been they kind of have sorts
they're kind of drifting a little bit I and
it so I don't think you'd necessarily like
those shows particularly but that's not for
me to say ask him when they clone him what's your
argument that star trek is better than star wars
well my argument is I wouldn't say that star
trek is better than star wars I would just say
that it's different I it's my friend mel gilden
says the golden age of science fiction is 13.
and of course by that he means that when you're
a 13 year old that's when you find those things
in science fiction that really speak to your
heart and the universes you want to live in
it's just for me I remember when I
was a kid I recorded the original
broadcasts of star trek on reel-to-reel tape in
case the show never aired again and there were
no vcrs there's no way to record the entire show
where you can watch it but I remember that week
after week after week there were stories that I'd
never seen anywhere before they were astonishing
and they had such profound meaning for my life
I remember a city on the edge of forever where
kirk and spock and mccoy go back to the 30s and
kirk falls in love with this woman who runs a soup
kitchen and ultimately he finds out that in order
for the time flow of time to turn out correctly
she has to die and so he literally allows her
to be hit by a truck he throws her into a truck
and every tv show I'd ever seen before that the
hero saved the girl it was just a given and in
this one he's responsible for the death of the
girl and and the message was sometime in your life
there'll be something is the right thing to
do but it'll break your heart but because it's
the right thing to do you have to do it and I was
profoundly changed by that one episode that harlan
ellison wrote and and I and and so star trek
had a deep deep formative influence on me and
whereas I can't say that luke or leia or obi-wan
or any of those characters as much as I like them
changed me in any way particularly other
than entertaining me for a few hours
so so I'm not I think if someone thinks that star
wars is better than star trek more power to them I
think it's fine for anyone to have any opinion
basically as long as it doesn't hurt anyone
I think compassion has to be what rules us and
it's it's so liberating when you don't need to be
right when you say this is just my opinion if
you have a different opinion it's fine that does
of course that doesn't mean racism or misogyny
or any of those things you have to speak out
against things that are really hurting people
but most opinions are just people having opinions
is star wars better than star trek I don't know
not for me but for other people sure it's fine
like when jj abrams loves star star wars I mean
I'm sure that he feels really bad that he wasn't
able to to do everything he wanted to do with it
so luck of the draw it reminds me a little bit of
the keith richards biography where he talked about
a lot of these jazz enthusiasts and there were two
different types there were the ones that were
sort of schooled in the bars and and had learned
to play yes by ear and then there were others that
had these theories and they would argue it and the
film world feels like that at times yes well I
have I have very little patience with theorists
it's funny I think of the twilight zone
companion as an oral history of the twilight
zone I was very lucky that all all the writers
directors producers actors were alive with
very few exceptions I mean rod sterling was gone
one of the other writers charles bowman was gone
but most everyone else was alive and so I was able
to get the direct story from the people who made
these shows who wrote them and directed and
produced them and the cinematographer and so forth
and but when you have theorists it's like I don't
really want to hear people's theories I don't care
about that it's so academic and so pointless I
would rather hang out with people making something
as opposed to people commenting about something
and it's funny because when I wrote the twilight
zone companion I wrote it to learn how to be a
writer producer in television not and so then when
people offered me gigs to write books about other
tv shows I always said no because that wasn't why
I did that book I didn't do that book to then
write the making of mash or the making of hello
kitty or whatever any of anything my little pony
but so I and and it's funny because on dvds and
blu-rays I'll always listen to the commentaries of
the directors or the writers of the sh of the film
or tv show but when it's some guy some theorists
like he's the head of the film department at
some university and he has this this theme about
alienation or whatever it's like I don't go away
it's not it's not worth my time and it's not of
interest to me that doesn't mean that you can't
have larger meanings or metaphors or any of that
but ultimately for any film or tv show or book
or any work of art to have relevance it has to
touch you here it has to move you emotionally
we love van gogh not because of the theory
of what he's doing we love ango because those
paintings speak to us they move us and so that's
the one thing I do like about the modern age is
authenticity is valued now so for instance
if people recognize me as an authentic person
and that my work is in alignment with who I am
as a person or the people I mentor the run the
roundtable I run if everything I do from mr
sci-fi to the round table to space command
to all these things are all in a line they
all speak to the same compassions they speak
to the same kindness people recognize that I'm
authentic in what I say and do and I'm very glad
that that matters because when I started my
career the only time someone in the audience would
encounter something of some work of mine is by
reading a book I'd written or watching a tv show
I might get a fan letter or maybe meet someone
at a convention now the audience is directly in
communication with me and I actually like that
because it tells me I'm i'm on the right path
because I know and I don't need the fans I don't
need the fans to tell me what to do artistically
but it's nice to know that what I'm setting out to
do is being accomplished so it's great well that's
the problem it's people who are in the ivory tower
people who are I mean particularly like it's like
people who didn't know anyone who made that
film or anyone who made that tv show it's like
some expert on howard hawks but he didn't know
the guy and free and frequently they'll come up
with all these reasons why something was done that
has nothing to do with why it was really done it
could be they were losing the light so that's why
he shot it as a one or like one with without cuts
it might not have been a stylistic choice it
might even the light was gone or there's always
things that come out great through the wonderful
chaos that production is you always see the lovely
see if I wanted total control over what I was
doing I'd be a novelist because novelists can
sit in their little rooms and the universe can be
exactly the way where they want it in their work
and then they give it to the editor and they
can take those notes or not take those notes
but they're sort of the god of that universe
they create I love to collaborate I love what
actors bring in my work what what designers bring
my work what everyone brings to my work I love
collaboration because there's such an element of
surprise if you choose people who are talented
and brilliant and passionate the work they come up
with will surprise you when an actor takes a for
instance there was a in the pilot of space command
there was a monologue I wrote for bob picardo
where he talks about the death of his wife and
when I wrote it I said this probably won't work
but I'll try it and I can always cut it out and
then bob delivered it and it's astonishing it's
wonderful and and so I was really glad I trusted
my actors and said okay I'm not convinced let me
see what he can do with it and he surprised me
because he really went somewhere truthful and
and that was that was me partnering with someone
who made my work better so I have nothing but
gratitude what makes the twilight zone different
from everything else quality it's good okay
the twilight zone is possibly the
best television show ever made
I think there's an argument argument that
can be made for that rod sterling never
wanted to be a science fiction writer he wanted
basically to be the arthur miller of television
and when he was censored when he couldn't write
about politics when he couldn't write about race
there were so many things he wanted to write
about and the censors just would not allow it
and his work he felt his work was being turned
into meaningless crap because of these limitations
he thought well if I do science fiction maybe I
can slide these things past and they won't notice
what I'm actually doing and that that's worked
it worked exactly he he ended up writing four
pilot scripts for the twilight zone before the
show got greenlit he was very determined to to
have that happen and so I think it came from the
fact that this was a man who had a lot to say and
knew how to say it twilight zone just isn't about
the gimmick the gimmicks are great and the twist
endings and all of those things are wonderful
and the fact that it was science fiction and a
horror and fantasy allowed it to be universal
in a way that had he just been writing about
ed medgar evers or something it wouldn't have
been because then it would seem very dated and the
writers from that era of live television generally
are not well known tad moselle or reginald rose or
even patty chayebsky had sterling stayed in live
tv and not created twilights and he'd probably be
forgotten now as good as requiem for heavy weight
was or patterns but but because he was forced
to write in this wonderful genre and write on
universal themes fear alienation loss of identity
it just created these amazing stories and
his scripts were so good that they would get
the top actors actors who often wouldn't do
television and and you got bernard herman and
jerry goldsmith these amazing composers and george
clemons this phenomenal cinematographer it's just
you look at the best episodes of the
twilight zone there are a lot of them
and you're just you hold your breath they're
so beautiful in every way and timeless and and
they work and even when what the story is you're
moved by these people because rod had a genuine
sympathy and empathy for the little guy for
someone working in as a bank teller or a woman
who's a secretary or he's not writing generally
about presidents or kings or wealthy people
he doesn't even though he himself was one of the
best paid writers in television he's not fawning
he doesn't idolize the rich like some writers
have he's some he's a regular guy he's a he's you
can get the sense that he has this big heart he
really cares deeply and he's coming from the heart
and again when I was talking a few minutes ago
about authenticity rod when you see rod sterling
on television he's exactly that guy I mean I've
seen videos of him teaching classes where he
wasn't he knew these wouldn't be broadcast and he
was absolutely himself warm and funny and smart
and and caring and and that really comes
across on twilight zone this is a man saying
here's a story I want to tell and I'm sharing it
with you or here's these other writers that I've
brought aboard who have these wonderful
stories to share with you it's his gift
to the audience and it holds up because
it's not about something trivial the
twilight zone is about something profound
deeply profound and its meaning conveys
to the younger generation as much as to
the audience it was made for back in 1959.
have you seen every episode oh yeah okay
what would you say the top five I've actually
when I when I started writing the twilight zone it
was two years twilight zone companion it was two
years after rod's death and carol sterling his
widow was still living in the house in pacific
palisades his dog was there this irish setter
and all these everything was exactly as he'd
left there was one room that was just the awards
the six emmys and the peabody awards and on and on
and so in the garage there were film cans his film
cans of twilight's on episode 16 millimeter prints
it was part of his contract that he would get two
prints of every episode because there's no vcrs
there was no home recording back then so often
I would go home with a stack of these film cans
and put them on the projector and they had the
original commercials in the original coming
attraction spots and many of these had never
even been put through a projector they were just
pristine they were gorgeous and so yeah and there
were four episodes that weren't in syndication and
then there was an a season and 18 episodes that
were hour-long episodes that weren't generally
syndicated every now and then they'd pop up but
yeah I had to do a little bit of pursuing some of
these episodes that were not in the in the general
audience though one of the funniest stories
in that regard was that I was researching the
twilight zone companion and this was just as vcrs
were starting to become available for purchase but
they weren't widely available so I recorded the
episodes off the air on reel to real tape I'm on
cassette tape and rod didn't have copies of every
episode it got more and more hit and miss as the
seasons went on and so at one point they were like
I think two episodes that I could just not two or
three episodes that they just never aired on ktla
so which was syndicating twilight zone so I called
the station manager and I said listen I'm doing a
book on on the twilight zone and I there's three
episodes I need to see and I want to find out when
you're going to be airing them because I really
need to see them he said well what episodes are
they and I told him he said well we'll broadcast
them next week so all of la watched the episodes
just because I needed to see them oh wow I thought
he was going to just have me in and maybe screen
them for me but nope everybody got to see him and
so that was that was really funny and wonderful
but but it was great that I was able to do to
produce the blu-ray set and do 52 commentaries and
and now of course I'm going to do the the rest
of them 104 that are left and so people will
be able to buy buy all of them so they'll be able
to hear everything I know about twilight zone and
for all of the episodes it's going to be great fun
if you had to choose what would be the top five
I love walking distance which was rod's personal
favorites about a man who goes back in time to his
own childhood it's a wonderful episode on thursday
we leave for home which is a great episode that
rod wrote with james whitmore it's one of the
hour ones I have the eye of the beholder which
is the woman whose head is wrapped in bandages
waiting to see if she's been made to look normal
nightmare twenty thousand feet which is the
gremlin on the wing with william shatner that
richard donner directed it's a great episode
I mean I could I could list 20 I mean and
it's a good life with billy mummy that's a great
one where he's got the power to do to terrorize
a small town but again I could easily pick death
ship miniature there's so there's so so many in
praise of pip there's just it just goes on and on
time of last with burgess meredith is the last man
on earth there's just I mean week after week after
week after week it was an astonishing artistic
feat what he was what he was pulling off it was
no one has ever really equaled it I don't think
what's your writing process I work five days
a week minimally sometimes six sometimes seven
but I prefer not to I'm always thinking about
a story or there's always something going on
here in my head I don't have regular
writing hours at various times I have
but now because I'm writing and producing and
directing and doing books as well my day is
split up into smaller chunks and I'm often
doing many different tasks in a given day
because I have full-time editor full-time
line producer vfx team all of that
so when I sit down to write I try to write for
several hours minimally I but I but it's like I
but I can also write on the fly if I need to I can
write almost anywhere I can write in a moving car
I've written in jeeps traveling through
the jungle in thailand when I did a pilot
for nbc that was shot there I mean it's like I I'm
often working on several scripts simultaneously
I'm always reading several books at the same
time and then I'll come up with ideas and I'll
jot them down I'll save those and sometimes I'll
i'll I'll write them or I won't I mean one of the
ideas I came up with recently that I liked was
well two two I came up with that I liked one was
I heard about the slave revolt in haiti where they
actually succeeded in freeing themselves and I
thought what would have happened if before
the civil war that it happened in america
that had spread to america and then now it's the
modern day and there's a separate country of free
of of the descendants of freed black slaves so
the south it's like it's not the confederacy one
won the civil war and we've got two americas
it's that there's a black nation where those
slaves freed themselves and what would that
look like and what would our country look like
and that was an interesting idea and another
idea I came up with which was rather amusing
was just a short story where someone would
have a chance to go back in time one time
and there's an artist who never got his
due was never recognized for his talent
and died without knowing that anyone
would would cared about his art
he'd been rejected a lot during his lifetime
so he goes back and convinces the official art
authorities to like take him in and accept him
and do shows of his paintings and so forth and
the way it would be structured is we would believe
throughout the story that it's vincent van gogh
but in the end it's adolf hitler because if hitler
had succeeded as an artist right he never would
have gone into politics he wouldn't have there'd
be no nazi party none of that and so it just it
just struck me as a funny story that that hitler
had he just been appreciated for his artwork it
would have really changed that century so it was
just a but but again so I come up with many many
ideas like for instance when I mentioned sitting
down to come up with 200 ideas it's actually up to
300 now ideas for movies or tv shows where I just
jot them down and and and sometimes I'll i'll I'll
pursue them it varies there are certain ideas that
I definitely will write like with space command
I knew I was going to do that and I knew that I
would write the entire season which which I have
and then we'd shoot it so but I'm always
working on something I'm never lying fallow and
some scripts it's like like over the next few
months we'll be rewriting this the final six
hours of season one of space command but meantime
I plan to write I mean we're also gonna write and
shoot all all the other five pilots of the
show runners network and so that's so we've
written sweethaven now and again it's always
just who are the characters what is the idea
how does this move how does this grow what is it
saying but it's always through characters I mean
it's with with sweet haven part of the genesis
that was my friend michael harney he's in project
blue book he's in orange is the new black he's
in for all mankind and yet he never gets these
wonderful lead roles that he should and so I said
well how would you like to play a cop and be the
lead in sweethaven where all the people under 60
die and but I also created his brother who will
also be playing who went the exact opposite path
and is very s dangerous and I thought that would
be fun too because I have my physical trainer
who I've been with for 30 years elaine and I both
he had an identical twin brother who was very very
different from him and so that became of interest
to me so it isn't just using a cliche from soap
operas of the twins the good twin and the bad twin
it's just the interesting thing of someone who
goes very different from someone who looks like
him it's just fun and and then so it's but but any
given week I'm writing I'm working in my producer
capacity so I'll be meeting with my vfx team
and reviewing vfx shots I'll be marketing I'll
be doing the mr sci-fi stuff I'll be building
my audience it's all part of the job it's all
I am in directing I mean today we were just
getting the sets ready to get them get them up
and running so it's exciting it's fun when you
were riding in the jeep through the jungles of
oh you were typing yeah I can type in
a moving vehicle and so this wasn't on
like a legal pad you were actually okay yeah
yeah I can write it on on a legal pad but but
it's easier to type in a moving vehicle because
when you're jostled and you're trying to write
you kind of do that but but I'm very fortunate
I think it's because when I was a kid I read
books my mom would have me in the back seat
and I would read voraciously and I think the
fact that I did that all kind of meant that I'm
not I don't get carsick and so so yeah and and
often I've had to write under deadline in those
kind of circumstances I can write with music
playing I mean I can be in like a busy coffee
shop or something and I'm not distracted so I
just go into that world and so it's very fun
how did you figure out your writing process
well in television you have deadlines and so
you just have to get very you write very fast
you'll have maybe a week or two to write an entire
script the hardest I have I ever had the hardest
experience was I had to write two hour scripts
in one week for two different series there was
one period of three months where I was writing
I think nine scripts for six different shows
and and I could juggle between outlining I'd be
outlining one while writing the script for another
but there were two shows they would not budge
on the deadline and so the way I did that was
I would write 10 pages of one in the morning
have lunch to clear my head then write 10 pages
the other one in the afternoon and I did that for
six days straight so at the end of six days I had
two 60 page scripts and one was forever night
and the other was space precinct and they both
got shot they both got made and and then another
time I wrote 55 pages in one day which was for
I think an animated show called black star and
elaine was a faster typist that was back when we
were on typewriters and so I was writing the pages
freehand and handing them to a lane she was typing
and at the end of the day I had the entire
script written so and that got made too of
course and so there's something there's a very
different energy where that everything you write
will get made it's it's then it becomes very
pragmatic it's not like you you don't you don't
wait for inspiration you put in the work you just
it's like if I have to write an entire script over
a weekend I can I will I prefer not to but but
I find that qualitatively there are scripts that
I've written in a week that were every bit as
good as scripts that took me a year and so I'm
it's I'm I have faith in my abilities after
all this time I know what I can do though
you have to know the story you're telling
because you can't afford to get lost in your
script it can't go south you have to know that's
why outlining particularly in tv is so important
because you have to know what what the structure
is what how it tracks that doesn't mean you can't
depart from that if you're going somewhere better
but you just can't there's not a lot of room for
that wild experimentation so but but but usually
I find that I'm my I'm clearest in terms of my
writing in the afternoons so I'll usually write
in the afternoons but I can write any time that
I need to write if I'm under the gun and I
remember one time when we were shooting the
first hour of space command bob picardo mentioned
that I referenced the wizard of oz in an early
scene that he had with doug jones but I didn't pay
it off and so we were going to be shooting that
like a few days later and I woke up in the
morning with the entire scene in my head
that paid off the wizard was and so while so I
said to elaine you drive and so while we were
driving to the studio I typed the scene and
then when we got to the studio I went into
the office and said print this out then I gave it
to doug and to bob and that that day we shot it
so but that was because bob was right he had a
great note and but it was just like but that's
how sometimes the process is like that other
times it's other times you'll have to go through
draft after draft after draft and and hopefully
find find your way but but tv has a much shorter
runway so you better be able to take flight when
you run out of the the landing strip it's you you
better be able to hit the air and I but that's
why but I love the speed of television and I love
the fact that most the what what you write gets
made it's I never could have had a happy life
as a screenwriter I don't think that would have
been for me at all well that was my next question
is what would your advice be to someone who
doesn't have the advantage of a deadline they
are their own deadline yes and and they are their
own audience for a while work with a timer that's
what I do we all have timers in our in our phones
so say okay I'm going to write you have to write
on a regular basis you have to have a discipline
and it's not so if you say my writing hours are
going to be from 9 a.m to 12 noon and and you find
a space where you're not going to get distracted
you find a writing space it could be at a
starbucks it could be a corner of your home
it doesn't matter where it is but it's that's
your writing place and people know it's your
writing place and they know that your time that's
your writing time and it's sacrosanct you don't do
other stuff in that in those hours and you set
your alarm for three hours or two hours or one
hour whatever it is and you sit there and even
if nothing comes you sit there you do the work
and and you treat it just like a job just like if
you're working at a shoe store you're working for
yourself but you cannot just watch tv you cannot
go you know talk with your pals no you're a writer
and but also setting a deadline for when a draft
will be done is very important so you just say
okay three weeks from now I'm going to have a
draft written it doesn't have to be good it just
has to be this beginning middle and end and then
you can go back and revise but just you just you
go and if and but professional writers need to
treat it like a job the best schedule of anyone
I ever knew was ray bradbury he would write five
days a week he would get up in the morning right
until lunch time then he would have lunch then
he would take a nap and in the afternoon he would
attend to business and then evenings and weekends
were for the family and he did that for over 70
years so pretty phenomenal well these wonderful
things that we have in our pockets to shoot film
also are a distraction and now we can check news
and now everything that we're interested in is now
going to be reflected back over and over again
and you have to be careful I mean again you can
lose yourself in all of these pursuits
but ultimately at the end of the day it's
like how committed I am to say how
committed am I to what I say I want
and because at the end of the day the
if you don't believe it no one else will
and the only way they can believe it is if you
get things finished if you get things out there
if you I I mean nobody ever says I want to be
a brain surgeon but I want it to be really easy
it's they know that you you put in work it's like
and but but people think that writing is going
to be easy it's not some days it's easy some days
it's hard but fortunately if you're doing it right
the audience can't tell what was hard and what was
easy which is fun which is really fun when it's
easy when it's good and and it comes easily it is
good I'm not deluding myself when it's hard though
I can struggle and struggle
and if I nail it ultimately
the audience has no idea that was difficult it
flows so that's a relief so but it's but it's
the script is just the blueprint the script is
just the arrow pointing the way I don't I mean
for instance I have to decide like today we were
having an actress try on one of the costumes to
see if it worked we were deciding if she would
be on a bed in this hospital room or if she would
be in like this this cylinder thing that would be
like with tubes plugged in and things and computer
panels and stuff and so it's like that's part
of the writing process too determining what the
lighting is going to be is it going to be subdued
is it going to be bright what color is it going to
be what lens are we going to be using these are
all creative decisions I've been acquiring like
I own I think 14 or 15 spacesuits now so I acquire
them from different productions or my mom got me
one when I was a kid and and then you redress
them I get sets from the best place to get sets
from is big budget science fiction movies that
tanked because no one saw them and the production
design is great and then you you redress them
so they're yours but it gives you this level of
just artistry and and detail and they because
they put so much money into it so you so that's
and that's a trick I learned from rod sterling
because when he shot twilight zone at mgm he
used every prop and costume and set that they had
and when I was a producer at sliders on sliders at
universal I said can I use everything from every
universal production ever made and they said huh
no one's ever asked that let me find out and they
came back and they said with a very few exceptions
yes and we were using stuff from jurassic park
and time cop and 12 monkeys and on and on it was
fabulous the best little whorehouse in texas we
shot one of our episodes in that house so but it's
I'm in the business of being ingenious and so the
more I come up the more I pull a rabbit from a hat
the more that I come up with a clever idea the
more I say okay this is this is the way to get
where we're going it's a series of problems that
need to be solved but it's a joyous process and
I mean to take something that's just in your head
and put out in the world so everyone can see it
it's just it's just there's no there's nothing
like it it's wonderful when when it comes together
it's great I love that process
and I feel part of a tradition I
feel in a way that rod sterling and harlan
ellison and all these wonderful people who
inspired and and guided me I'm part of that
tradition the reason I like to mentor people
is because I feel that I can then pass on what
I've learned from from these amazing people and
it doesn't end with me I'm just part of the part
of the process part of the flow have you ever
mentored someone or met someone that you could
just tell they weren't going to be teachable
yes I have and and the lovely thing is I don't
ever assume that I have to succeed with anybody
like one of the rules of my round table when I
started was there's no any everyone is welcome
if they come with a good heart there's no
decision as to who's deserving notice no
decision as to who has talent or who's going to
make it or not if someone comes with a good heart
writers producers actors directors editors
composers anybody they're welcome because
we're creating a community a supportive community
when I mentor people if they're just not going to
get it I just stop talking because it's sort
of like this when they'll say well this is
what I'm going to do and I'll say well that's
probably not going to work I don't and I'm not
usually not that blunt but I'll say well here's
a few other ideas that would I think be easier
to make happen and if they just are resistant to
that they say okay well go with god and also if
they come back and say I did that and it worked
I'll say great because again I don't need to have
there's no there's no one way to do it
there's a lot of ways to fail of course
giving up is a really bad idea because when you
give up it guarantees that nothing's gonna happen
but if but you can't just keep failing and failing
and failing you figure out what's going wrong some
people can't write and if you can't write but
you want to make film or make tv then they'll
affiliate with someone who's got the talents you
don't have and do what you can do do what you're
good at some people for instance guillermo
del toro told me he's not great with dialogue
so he he's good with plot good with imagery my
god but so he affiliates with people who write
dialogue well you find the person like when
I mentioned earlier that I direct with elaine
could I learn the skills that elaine has to work
with direct with actors yes I could I could learn
those skills and I'm not terrible I mean I can
I can work with actors I do know what the what
the through line emotionally is and so forth but
but elaine having been an actor and gone to drama
school and directed off broadway she has a depth
of she has a bag of tricks that I don't have but
but because I'm collaborating with
her I don't have to learn that stuff
because she has it so I can say well how do we get
this how do we get this effect how do we get this
actor to do this thing and she'll then talk to
them and it's like wow great so and sometimes
it's miraculous to me like it's like how did you
do that so good and so that's that's really fun
but on the other hand I had to teach her to like
not think of it like directing a play it's like
look at the monitor see that angle is not a good
angle so like turn them this way and now now
she's much more savvy to to camera angles and all
that kind of stuff so we we learn from each other
can you explain why outlining matters to all the
screenwriters who are set against it yeah I mean
you don't want to outline such a degree that
you have no juice left for the script it's not
it's not like building a concrete wall
around yourself that you can't break out of
it's basically to give you the bones of structure
so where your story is going now in television
outlining is much more important because if
you're under the gun if they're going to be
shooting in three weeks or two weeks or tomorrow
you you can't go off into left field you have so
that's when outline really needs to be nailed down
in features see but what what this really speaks
to is you need to you need to know understand
how structure works because structure I early
in my career I struggled a lot with structure and
then there was one period one summer where I was
writing I think all the episodes of a series for
cbs and I was writing so much and so quickly all
of a sudden it just clicked in it was like it went
right into the groove and suddenly structure was
simple for me it was just like built it was like
the bones of a house and the bigger the story the
bigger the house but it's like the framework that
holds it all together and I understood that and
then it became just second nature it was very
funny when I when michael reeves and I were
outlining the the sulu story the star trek
story that we we did with george takei
we were both old hands michael was the
one writer who got me into television
at one point we're outlining the steps and jotting
it down and then about two-thirds of the way
through we just looked at each other and michael
said you got this right and I said yeah and then
so we didn't outline the rest of it we both knew
where it went and then we just wrote it and but
again you have to be a really old hand to know
how to do that stuff but but outlines are great
because then well rod used to say rod certainly
you say that if he knew the ending he could write
a script but if but he said I've got so many
stories where it's a beginning and a middle and
no end and he said I can't write those because
I don't know where they go I don't know how they
resolve and so outlining rigorously outlining
means the beginning the middle and the end and
because you do not want to get lost in the
middle and or at the beginning or anywhere
because a story has to satisfy the viewer it has
to come to an end where you go okay well that
was worth my time and and so outlining is very
important it's not I've again if you come up with
a better idea while you're writing okay if but you
have to know that it is a better idea you can't
think oh well that didn't pay off if it doesn't
work don't do it it's better to follow an outline
that works rather than experiment but but
the more you write the stronger you get
at this stuff and you just learn you learn your
craft and craft is structure craft is outlining
because that's just how it works it's I it's like
I write short outlines I don't I don't I would
never write like a 30 or 40 page outline but like
the most I would do for an outline would be maybe
seven pages for an hour script and with novels
I I'll jot notes I don't rigorously outline
for novels but I know the structure I know where
the story goes and I know who does what but
but there are writers who don't outline
who are still very very good and succeed
but if you're just starting out I think outlining
is a really important tool I would urge everyone
to utilize it but but at the end of the
day it's getting to the end of the story
and however you got there if it works it
doesn't really matter how you got there
outlines are just a tool how would you teach story
structure to someone who needs help I would say
watch movies that you feel have a satisfactory
ending and break write down the write down the
scenes write down what happens write down how the
characters move through it and what the story does
and see why that satisfies why that works years
ago I was hired to do a pilot where one of the
characters was a gangster the sort of a bad guy at
the beginning but then he helps these two kids and
he turns out to be a good guy and I thought well
how how did they do that trick how did like how
do you do a trick where you like somebody even
though they're a bad guy at the beginning and so
I watched casablanca and I saw that everything
bogart says is cynical but everything he does
is moral is ethical and his actions are speaking
louder than his words it was a very simple trick
and a very subtle one but it worked like
gangbusters it was terrific and so that once I
knew to do that that told me where I could go and
so you there's thousands of tv shows and movies
don't don't try and invent stuff from whole cloth
study structures that worked a structure is like
a machine it's like you don't I don't I always
say don't steal plots but study structure because
there's stuff that works and stuff that doesn't
work and the more you deviate from standard
structure the better the writing has to be so for
instance quentin tarantino can use very unusual
structures but the writing has to really be solid
and so that's just the way the way that works
how do you write a scene
you try to have every scene have an
emotional point okay you you try to
avoid scenes that are just exposition that's
a trap that people fall into where everyone's
talking just to explain twists in terms
of the story and they're boring scenes
come from character who's who needs what who
wants what who's longing for what who's hiding
what they're really feeling who's not seeing
what's going on in their heart or in their
head you find the juice of the scene usually
it's conflict but not always you find something
I mean usually the way it works with an audience
is the structure is familiar the details of the
story are fresh so in other words like if you
go to a certain movie okay this is most likely
going to have a happy ending okay but what the
characters say how they get there that's where
you can surprise an audience and that's where you
can engage them and so so it might be a story from
your life or someone or something you read or any
number of things I mean everything I write is a
synthesis a combination of everything and anything
for instance I knew I wanted to do a scene in
space command that was in spanish because one of
our actors was was from venezuela and he's very
charming and very very good victor manso and so
when I did the bonus episode during the pandemic
I said okay I'm going to write a scene
where he's calling his estranged father
to invite him to his wedding and and
so I wrote the scene in english and
I originally wrote the role of the father to be
guillermo del toro I reached out to guillermo
and he wasn't available at that point for various
personal reasons but but guillermo had had certain
elements from his childhood that actually wove
into that that scene and and it was about the son
introducing his fiancee to the father and trying
to get the father to come to mars in that case
to attend the wedding and ultimately they want
the father to move in with them and it's about
a father's disappointment in his son's
choices and then finally coming to
accept who his son is and see the commonality
between the two of them and it's a lovely scene
and I was really glad to do it in spanish because
I love the idea of having different languages in
space command for instance mira furlin and the
actress who play her daughter speak cerbeau
in when they talk to each other and but it's a
great scene with the father and the son and the
fiance because you stop realizing it's in spanish
you're so engaged in the people and reading the
subtitles and so and I had victor translated
into spanish and every now and then he'd say well
it can't be this exact thing but this will make
sense culturally and I said sure fine great and
but I really love that scene because there's an
emotional truth in it and so that's that's great
every now and then I'll write a scene that's
just for the gosh g whiz a rocket ship taking
off or something like that battle on titan
or whatever it's very funny because we were
shooting the battle on titan where these synthetic
humans they're soldiers they're gunning down these
these freedom fighters who are human and one of
the extras didn't show up so I said well I'll put
on a space suit I said but you have to you have to
disintegrate me so I'm in the space when I get hit
by a laser blast and disintegrate with a scream
and it was great fun great fun yeah bourbon was
great at that too what is it sonata the piano
player or daughter they come she's right and
then or no no sorry the piano player mother and
then the the social worker daughter and and it's
you don't need subtitles to the tension and the
emotion well now we have thanks to netflix we know
that foreign tv shows can be successful here
and the people will read subtitles and that's
fabulous I'm i'm I'm oh yeah I'm so glad of
that well I don't mind me reading subtitles
I absolutely love foreign films but yeah it helps
to read so yeah it does yeah this comes in handy
and not just ramona cleary books nothing
against them yeah there you go I like those
we've heard that and you said this
the other day on your livestream solid
we've heard that you say you don't come up with
story lines unless there's a chance to utilize
them why is that well I might come up with an idea
but the ones that I really dig in on and write the
script I'm writing that to shoot it I'm writing
it to make it I'm not I'm not writing it's not an
exercise I never write just for like the I was
gonna say the fun of it I do write for the fun
of it but I don't write something that's just
gonna be in a drawer that's that's purposeless
and and and also my heroes when I was a kid like
rod sterling like ray bradbury they wrote books
and tv shows and movies they could do all three
and so I've always throughout my career written
books tv is my main form tv is my main art form
and my art form of choice but I've always written
books I've always written screenplays as well
and so and the books were I'm really proud of the
books I've done and the twilight zone companion
the book with guillermo green lighting yourself
the magic time trilogy of novels they've all I'm
really glad I got to do them they were well worth
doing well what if someone says well I don't I'm
not there yet I don't have anyone to to pitch to
or I haven't assembled my team or we can crowdfund
and make this what's your advice to that I mean so
they should they still be writing just to utilize
them not just to sit in a drawer you have to learn
your your craft you have to know how to tell a
story and you need to get feedback so that if
something works or doesn't work but on the other
hand if you're shooting you learn very quickly
when you're shooting if something works because if
the actors can't deliver it or I really encourage
people to shoot what they've written at least
to see how it works when actors are saying it
I mean you you get a wealth of knowledge from
making it because the script again is is such
a quiet object whereas if if you make a short or
a feature that can start getting attention that
can start get and and if it doesn't work you
say oh those characters don't sound realistic
I have to work harder on my dialogue or or
whoa this this scene was really boring there
was really nothing happening there it's things
will become incredibly clear when you shoot them
and and that's again where television is such
a great learning ground because when everything
you write gets made you very quickly learn what
an actor can say and what they can't and and you
you it's a very fast learning curve and I'm very
grateful for that and but I would say to anyone
be bold don't be I was gonna say don't be afraid
you can be afraid but there's a there's a saying
that I have in my wallet which is the bolder I am
the better things go and that's so true if you if
you fall on your face you'll get up again I people
say well life is like a river and it takes you
where you're meant to go I say I say to people
if you fell in a real river you wouldn't say
that you'd swim like hell for the shore it's like
don't don't just let let things carry you along
figure out what you want and and but really go for
it it's like failure is not a terrible thing they
don't take you off to writer's jail it's they
if you fail get better it's a process and and
and also by the way sometimes what you write some
people will like it some people won't but if they
really like it if you polarize people where some
people really love it and some people really hate
it that's not bad I mean look at the work of david
lynch you don't have to please everyone you just
have to please someone and the first person
you have to please is yourself and the way
you please yourself is by saying I got that right
that came out well that was that was great and so
so the lovely thing is that it used to be that you
had to come here to hollywood to make dreams come
true and now you can make them come true anywhere
if you're in east mckeesport pennsylvania or or
kuala lumpur you can still we've all got phones
we've all got video cameras we've all got the
internet it's make use of what's at hand you're in
the 21st century for god's sake you thank god but
don't waste the opportunity you could make it you
can make a short film this week don't wait don't
wait act ray bradbury had a wonderful sign over
his typewriter that I now have over my computer
that says don't think act and that's so true
it's what it actually is don't think do and it's
like yeah right on yes absolutely what was the
most polarizing david lynch work while at heart
doom probably doing okay well no but blue velvet
I mean I mean his one of my favorite david lynch
phrases elaine and I went to see mulholland
and at the end of that it was a mulholland
drive it's whichever one he directed mall in
the driver I think and at the end of the movie
the screen goes to black and there's that moment
where everyone in the audience is just sitting
in the darkness before the house lights come up
and someone yelled out what the [__] was that
and so but I understood what the story was so
in the lobby I started telling I was surrounded
by a crowd of people from the from the audience
telling them what the movie had been about what
it was because they had totally lost they had
no comprehension and then they said okay now we
get it but but again it's fine because the thing
about david lynch is he's following his aesthetic
purpose he is telling stories he wants to tell
that only he can tell great great if you only had
three rules in which to guide your screenplay
what writing rules would those be make sure make
sure that all the characters are distinctive from
each other and have their own distinctive way of
speaking and know what they care about know what
they want know them write them as as people not as
generic cab driver generic and whatever anything
tell a story that pays off in a meaningful way and
not just for the main character but try and have
it pay off in an emotionally satisfying way for a
variety of your characters and and have something
fresh in it fresh and fresh and meaningful
so that it isn't something you've seen a million
times I'm not here to write stories I've seen a
million times I'm here to write stories I haven't
seen a million times and and that doesn't mean it
can't be inspired by the tradition I write in
and it's fun like for instance in space command
all the space command personnel are named after
famous science fiction writers I grew up reading
so there's symac and sturgeon and bradbury and le
guin and and so forth and that's very fun and the
funny thing was at one point I had a character
named murray leinster after science fiction
writer from the 50s and and I cast victor manso
who's latino and I thought well he doesn't look
like a marie leinster so then I had to think of a
science fiction or fantasy writer a latino one and
finally I remembered jorge louis borges who's a
great fantasist from argentina and so I named the
character jorge borges and so that was fun that
was very fun so but I just I but I would just make
sure it has to be original truthful the characters
have to be vivid and it has to has to take us to
an emotional place that's satisfying those are
the those are the big ones and I mean a film can
have a lot of drawbacks for instance no one
script is going to be everything to everybody
you can't like for instance you might want to
write something about transgender rights at some
point and maybe maybe you'll put in a transgender
character in one script or maybe ultimately you
want to write about that in a big way that that
might be the the main drive of your story but
again I don't ever write message things you have
to have a story that's engaging elaine will start
with themes I rarely do I usually start with a
character or an actor that I want to work with or
it can be on almost anything it can be
almost anything and but I always arrive
at the same place which is a story that I want
to tell so just as there's the bechdel test
is there a message test so that we as filmmakers
okay yeah you know that that that it's a message
film if when the lights come up everyone's gone
so I mean I mean rod rod certainly used to be
very cognizant a lot to say politically and
socially but he knew that you had to create
characters that the the people cared about like
when burgess meredith is the last man on earth
you care about him you're engaged by that man and
and you feel sorry for him what happens to him
it's I mean I don't know any really good
writers who who don't put the focus on character
in science fiction whether it's deckard and
blade runner or whomever there's people that
you care about ripley and aliens I mean great
example you have to there's there's so many
films and tv shows where you don't care about the
people and you don't and it's just forgettable
it's just forgettable so it's really
important to to do that and and and again
I'm not here to change everyone's opinion my goal
is get is to convince people to be compassionate
and to convince people to be that that the power
of love is important that we're we are united
by our commonality far more than we're divided
by our opinions and so that's what I would urge
people to recognize and so that's I mean my big
message is compassion and that's a good message
I think to have why do we care about ellen
ripley we hear about ripley because she's
she well first of all in aliens she cares
about someone other than herself she's trying
to save that little girl even if she dies
she's willing to sacrifice herself but also
she's the smartest person in that movie she's the
most competent person in that movie that story is
about her where she starts traumatized and step
by step by step to save other people she has to
take control and command she knows what she's
doing and the fact and and again it's a great
marriage between character and actress because
corny weaver is able to play a powerful woman
where she's no less feminine she's just competent
and and you believe every single thing she does in
that movie it's terrific it's one of my favorite
films it's a great film how was she received how
was that character received at that time well
it's very funny when alien came out originally
ripley was a male character and they
changed through a female character and
and I thought it was great but my brother jim my
brothers grew up in orange county I grew up in l.a
when my parents divorced when I was three and my
brother jim said oh man that woman she was such a
[__] he was like so traditional now I think he'd
have a different opinion he was young back then
but it's like he was from a much more conservative
background it was like so he was like riled up
about having a woman character that's strong but
I thought it was just great I loved it from the
first so and that was what 83 79 79 oh sorry
79 aliens was 70 was 86. but the fun part was
before the pandemic 2019 I heard that there was
a high school there was a high school in east
in bergen new jersey and it was the the art
teacher and the english teacher had an idea
that instead of doing like brigadoon or oklahoma
for their high school play they would do alien
the entire movie and they built everything
from scratch the alien suit the the 15-foot
space jockey the space suits the chest burster
everything and they thought they'd just fly
under the radar that no one would hear about
it just the parents would come see it but then
of course it went viral so ridley scott put
up some money and they were able to put on
another performance and they were in the eye
of the media storm and so I flew to new jersey
to north bergen new jersey to spend the
day talking to the students so because I
knew they were going to get a lot of promises
from hollywood and I knew those would all be
false probably and would fall flat and their
hearts would get broken and I want to say here's
how it works and if you come to la I'm happy to
to guide you and you can all be members of my
round table wherever you are and so forth and so
I spent the day with them and then as a surprise
sigourney weaver showed up and she hung out with
the kids and she introduced the play and it was
just wonderful I actually posted the entire play
on mr sci-fi and it's great when the chest burster
comes out and there's blood everywhere it was
wonderful and and I said to them I said the kids
this is hollywood what you're doing right here is
hollywood hollywood is wherever you're creating
something that has meaning something that you gave
it your really best effort and and it was I'm so
glad I went it was a wonderful experience that's
great I'll have to check it out yeah we'll put a
link below this video it's really fun awesome
well people can watch the first hour of space
command they can watch the bonus episode they
can watch that they can watch my just sulu star
trek episode all on mr sci-fi sure are you an lane
yeah yeah just it's super fun yeah it's enjoyable
and then we can see your dogs too I love the fact
that I get to have my own network I mean I wasn't
planning that I just had lunch with glenn mizera
who was a friend of mine who was the show runner
on walking dead and we were having lunch and
he said you know so much about science fiction
you should have your own youtube channel and I
thought good idea and so so I called it mr sci-fi
and just started it up I didn't do anything really
to promote it now as I said we've had millions of
hits and closing in on 100 000 subscribers and
it was just like great because I can I can do
something short or something that takes a lot more
effort but it's it's really fun because I'm so
so enthusiastic about science fiction I've loved
it since I was a kid and sulu why should we care
about sulu well when I was a kid watching
star trek sulu was my favorite character
and because george k was just so great and he was
so smart and so competent and loyal and honorable
and just wonderful and he never got the great
sulu episode and I then found out that there were
a group of fans in upstate new york making their
own star trek episodes and walter kanye who played
chekhov was flying up there to make an episode
about his character and dorothy fontana who story
added the original star trek had written that
script so icon and my friend michael reeves back
when they were going to bring star trek back as
a series in the 70s came up with this great sulu
story and so I contacted the guys in upstate new
york and I said listen michael and I both wrote
for star trek the next generation the michael's an
emmy winner would you be interested in doing this
episode and they said sure and I said but I wanted
director and they said fine and and so then I went
to george and I typed up the outline of what the
story was going to be and I said look you you
never got the great zulu episode you you deserved
and I said this is it and so he said I'm in and
michael and I wrote the script and it took me six
months to prep and to a solid year we shot we shot
it in a matter of two weeks and then it was solid
year of editing and visual effects had 700 visual
effects shots and when we were shooting I said
to george next year you and I will be on in japan
speaking to the world science fiction convention
and screening this episode after which
we'll answer questions and you'll be answering in
japanese because he's fluent in japanese and I'll
be answering english and I said a year after that
will be nominated for the hugo which is the top
award in science fiction and all of that happened
oh wow and so because it was I'm i'm proud
I'm very very proud of that episode and it's every
every I gave every bit of everything I knew how to
do in that to write and direct and exactly produce
that and my contract was that no one could touch
a frame of it I had total directorial say and so
it's exactly what I wanted to be and as I say we
cast christina moses and she's phenomenal every
take was just gorgeous and I'm and I've worked
with her since she's in space command now as well
as being in the middle million little things on
abc but she and she'll be in magic time and some
of the other projects we're doing so it's fun
you build an ensemble of friends who who you
love to work with how much of what you write
is trying to be original versus trying to give
the audience what they want well I'm pleased
when the audience gets value from what I do but
that's not why I'm doing it I'm doing it because
I have something I want to say something I
have experienced or something I've observed
that's meaningful to me and it's so and and
there's just so many wonderful pieces I mean
the lovely part about what I do because of it's
science fiction I get to create a universe and
that's the thing that science fiction brings that
other genres don't tend to if if you see a story
set in the modern day it's just about those
people it's about that story but if you tell
a really good science fiction story the universe
is a separate character in a way like for instance
blade runner you can do stories in the blade
runner universe you can do stories in the star
wars universe or star trek universe and that's
extremely beguiling and I love that and it allows
you also to work with visual design and because
I was a painting sculpture and graphic arts major
I have a very strong visual sense and I also
know the history of science fiction design I
mean I think it's incredibly cool and unexpected
that we have big silver spaceships now thanks
thanks to elon musk they look exactly like
the ones I saw in when worlds collide or
on the book covers from my childhood and that's
just a thrill I love bringing a science fiction
reality to the screen it's it just you saw
so many of my of my skills and enthusiasms
do you think you'll be going up to space in
one of the various no carriers okay let's
see what happens there's a few to choose from
it's not something that I'm eager to do but
it's not something I wouldn't mind doing either
but I do know I personally know astronauts and
scientists at nasa and jpl and all that stuff
is really exciting so there's a member of our
roundtable who's a science fiction writer
and his day job is he drives the mars rover
oh that's a cool thing he has two watches one is
on earth time and one is on mars time which is
just super cool yeah sorry I'm late I was right
yeah I said a crater oh wait yeah wrong watch
but yeah it's very fun how do you build a
character from scratch well it can come from
a lot of places idea what I do is I keep a
list of people that I've known in my life
and actors that I love all of whom are very
distinctive and have different ways of talking and
every time I write a script I cast it with people
who are very distinctive in my mind in some cases
it's actors I'm gonna be working with so for
doug jones and bob picardo and mira furlin
and bill mummy I wrote those roles for them
for space command but in some cases it might
be an actor that I'm not going to get like for
instance I wrote a script called fugitive space
and the template I used for the lead was ed harris
in the abyss because it was a great character and
a great voice like it seemed very clearly in my
mind so I knew that ed harris wasn't going to play
that role he's too old for that role now for one
thing but but it made the character very real very
alive to me and so you just make sure that nobody
is just flat nobody's just there for exposition
you never I don't tend to describe the physicality
of a character because often you might have
something in mind but there might be an actor
who doesn't look a thing like that who's great
and you don't want to limit it and and I also
very much want diversity in my in my cast
asian black different countries as more
the better and so that's also part of the
part of the design I cast a lot of actors
from restaurants I eat at the waiters are all
the waiters and waitresses are all actors and
actresses and I'll if I find someone who's
good or who intrigues me I'll say send
me your reel and I'll i'll cast them
yeah I've done that a lot that's great I like that
yeah and also too you can see how on they are yes
there was there's a restaurant called granville in
the valley and there was a young actor who looked
exactly like he could be the son of ethan mcdowell
who plays jack kemmer the lead in space command
and he was an actor and I and I cast him he's
he's in the bonus episode and he's great he
does a great job so I'm going to he'll be in
more episodes coming up what mistakes do new
writers make in writing characters new writers
make a lot of mistakes in writing characters
usually the biggest mistake is they're just flat
they all sound alike and they just are saying
exactly what they're thinking in real life
people don't say what they're thinking generally
they might say what they're thinking directly
in an argument but often not not even then so
you want to think about how people really
talk and also remember that a script is not
a representation of real life it's like a 120 page
haiku and it's so it's it's an it's an illusion
of reality but it isn't reality and so often the
lines have to be a lot briefer and a lot punchier
but I always like to have characters who
talk differently from each other who are
very different in their outlooks their world
view also a mistake many writers make not just
in the beginning of the career their careers
but throughout is that it's about the plot
and the characters are just serving the plot and
that's not not a good idea you want the plot to
be servicing the characters in other words for
instance aliens has a wonderful plot but ripley is
at the core she's the heart of that movie and if
that movie were about people you didn't care about
that and that movie also by the way introduces a
wide variety of characters incredibly well so if
you look at when they all wake up from the sleep
pods and you see you meet all of those characters
they're very different from each other and they
have their own take and they're very you get who
they are really quickly and there's a lot of them
and so studying that just saying okay how did that
work and it works like a charm it's great it's
great and if you said so so because ripley was
not a flat character but if some things have been
slightly well if if she were a flat character you
wouldn't care about that movie it would just
how many movies are based on aliens were they
where they're like big science fiction movies and
because the characters are forgettable the movie
is forgettable you you don't you don't love movies
because of the plots generally you love movies
because of the characters and and and I think a
lot of films are too clever for their own good
because they're they're just twisting and turning
the plot in violation of the character and you
never want to do that because the moment the
audience distances from the character you've lost
them and and I don't I don't like puzzle boxes as
as a structure I like I mean you can have mystery
you can have revelations all of that that's
fine but I like to have characters who don't
you don't lose the characters because of what
the plot is doing and so that's yeah and you
don't throw them away either you you respect your
characters that doesn't mean they can't die they
can but but you give what they do meaning you
never just you never treat anyone as disposable
and in my opinion and so with the dialogue knowing
that it's going to be distinct for each character
you think a lot of new writers start out thinking
okay I'm going to do sort of an aaron sorkinisk
sort of very talky it's witty it's
well also that's another mistake that
beginning writers make which is they're they're
they're talking talking talking and talking like
get in and get out it's like make your point and
then on to the next scene don't belabor it so
they they're they're much too wordy and also yeah
imitating quentin tarantino imitating aaron sirkin
try not to I mean sterling said when he started
out he everything he wrote was bad hemingway and
he said everything began it was hot so and that's
forgivable in young people but again you have to
find your own voice you have to find and the way
to find your own voice is what do I care about
what do I know about what do I alone know what and
that it doesn't mean you can't write things that
are different from what you've actually lived
but what do about and what do you care about
what gets you riled up and what's where do you
live emotionally and find and and and then when
and and if you hear someone say something just
in their your your day I always carry a little
notepad with me and I jot things down because if
someone says a line that's like wow that's great
it's like I'll i'll utilize that and and try not
to rip off dialogue from other movies because god
it's so so many people rip off lines from aliens
it's like oh please don't and so that's part of it
and and and don't bore if if something's boring
to you on the page it'll be boring to everybody
so keep working on it until it works and sometimes
the scene doesn't work and the only way to make it
work is to get rid of it and so be willing to do
that it was funny I was giving notes to someone
last week and they were saying well does this
character work I read their script and gave
them notes and there was a script that had been
developed at big companies and he said there's
this character work I said no lose them they don't
work and I said and they're saying what about this
sequence saying no it doesn't work and I said
here's what your story is about emotionally it's
about a father and a son and son doesn't think
his father loved him but in reality his father did
love him and shielded him and sacrificed his own
life but the son doesn't know that and ultimately
our the son is willing to to do that for his own
daughter but the father's spirit saves them this
father comes back as a spirit it's a fantasy film
and and once I said this is what your plot is and
everything else is distraction and so don't
keep pulling it in this direction pulling in
the right direction follow the emotional line and
because that'll work and so then I just kind of
took it helped it along and again they don't
do they have to do my version of their film
no but they have to do a version that works and
and if that if my version helps them find their
their path great and because many films don't know
what they're trying to say or they have nothing to
say you know what what are most films about most
films are about two hours so it's like know what
you're trying to say and and then remove the stuff
that doesn't say that what's your favorite piece
of dialogue that you overheard personally that
you jotted in your little notebook yeah gosh
I don't remember and sorry about that it's like
I remember one of my favorite lines that I ever
wrote it's a terrible line it's terrible they're
in future space which is about a future where we
trade our worst prisoners with alien prisoners
they do they breathe methane we breathe oxygen
they're the prison that's holding the humans
is on a methane world so we can't escape
they can't escape our prison here on earth
because it's oxygen they don't breathe oxygen
and it's about a prison break that erupts
at a at the handoff point a space station
between the two races and the aliens are like
eight foot tall jelly vertical jellyfish they
communicate via chromatophores really fun and and
we're gonna be doing that as a tv show but the
I had this guard who was like really
sadistic and at the end he saves one
of our characters and he dies and when he
dies he says I don't know why I did that
and and his boss the prison the head of the
the guard says he was a prick but he had balls
it's such a stupid line but it's like that's
pretty good that's funny yeah and again you but
again it has to be that character who would say
that line and I think he was a dick but he had
balls whatever it is this but again the reason
that line I like that line is because this is
a script that has rougher talking characters you
never have that line in space command for instance
which is much more family show but fugitive space
has very rough language because it's convicts and
but it's about the industrial military prison
complex because ultimately two prisoners one is
a woman helicopter pilot who's been framed for a
wartime massacre and the other is a former cop who
killed his fellow officers because they were
going to murder a family he was a dirty cop
and that was the line he could not cross
but he killed them with premeditation
his brother officers and so he's a
trustee now in the prison but a convict
but they find out that the earth government
has struck a deal with the aliens the aliens
are fighting a war that they're losing and so
earth has struck a deal with them that they
can invade earth empty out all the ghettos and
use all the poor people to fight in their war
basically as slave soldiers and so our heroes have
to get back to earth and warn everybody and and
and build a counter insurgency so so it's about
something meaningful to me which is the the people
the underclass the people who anything can be done
to them because they don't quote unquote count
and I write about that thematically a lot the
people that people need to be given respect
people need to be seen as human and as as equal to
us in every way and so so it's going to be a very
interesting show but but I created the character
who speaks certain ways so that line works
in that in that context but the hero doesn't say
that I just have this tough prison had the boss
of the prison guard started with charles derning
I used charles durning as a model for that guy
and even though charles derning is an older actor
who passed away but it's very vivid in my head
so that allows me to write him so ah there you go
but I've written other lines but it it it depends
on any given day how does a screenwriter
know that what they've written is good
writers are often misled in their own opinions
of their work they think the script is great when
it's really not you need response from
others and you need to really listen
and not defend your work now
when you work in a mass medium
and you hear back from your fans or the show is
a success then and also as you get more and more
polished in your craft you often know
when something's at least competent
when you what will work but the funny thing
is I often write scripts and elaine is my
the person I get notes from and she often says
this needs to be better this needs to go deeper
it's like okay okay okay okay it's like and
that's good that's good because if something
doesn't have the depth or the or the emotional
line I need to know that and and and frankly
I wrote I wrote one of this two-hour scripts
of space command and we could absolutely shoot
that draft we absolutely could and it would more
or less work but it's not good enough so we're
going to scrap that entire draft and start over
again and I've actually already done that and
and there's characters we won't see that they're
in there and those characters work but but the
story as a whole isn't as good as we can make it
so we're going to go back to the drawing board and
that's fine it's harder work but but eventually
I may publish the lost worlds of space command
and include that script so people can see where
it started because it's an entertaining read but
I I need people in my life who tell me if
something's working or not but at some point you
draw the line you say okay we're we're rocking and
rolling we're not gonna because you can you can
endlessly rewrite and you there's a point where
that's again where television is good if they're
shooting on monday you gotta at some point you
gotta say well we're done and and roll camera so
you make it as good as you can but then remember
that when you're the writer producer director the
editing phase is the final draft of the script so
in fact with space command we're editing finishing
the first the second episode with the visual
visual effects and everything and I realized
there was one scene that we needed to add so we
went back to the dailies we called our actors we
got some adr lines we put together a scene that we
never shot and there it is and we'll have a visual
effects shot of this ship landing and planting a
part of a wrecked ship to use as an explosive on
the big alien ship and it'll work it'll and
no one will know that we never shot that scene
so it's I love the so it's pressed to depress
the digitation magic so it's fun what about
the reverse though what if someone says this is
horrible and I know this is crap and someone else
reads it and they're not there's no agenda for
this person and they go actually this is really
good no no this is terrible this is terrible if
the check clears if the check clears I mean if
someone wants to buy a script of yours it doesn't
matter what you think of it let them buy us
it's but but on the other end let's say you've
written something and you think it's crap
right and they love it or someone loves it and
encourages you the way if something if a note is
correct is that everyone is saying the same thing
so in other words if five people read it and they
all say I just hated when he killed the dog then
you better rewrite that but on the other hand if
one person loves it and you don't like it well
they don't have to I mean it's like then you can
say well let me let me see if there's something
of value here but don't don't be slavish to their
opinion they could easily be wrong so if they love
it that's fine if they're going to buy it let them
but but don't I mean you might reread your script
just with a mind toward what maybe they're valuing
but don't don't trust it as holy writ because
they're probably wrong and so but at the en it's
but that's very rare that someone
says something that you think it
doesn't work and other people
say it does that's very rare
that's what I was wondering it's yeah usually you
think it's great and other people think it sucks
yeah what a reality check how how delusional
writers yeah but but but there's always going
to be people who aren't on your wavelength so
for instance if I'm doing science fiction and
someone doesn't q into what I'm doing because
they're not a science fiction fan there's no right
or wrong to that it's just they are not their head
doesn't live where my head lives and that's fine
but they're not going to be my audience they're
not I don't need to convince them I don't need
to rewrite you have to be very careful
of bad notes notes that wreck your script
and you don't you that's where you really want to
make sure that the people who are giving you notes
understand what you're trying to do and can
make it better but not throw it out and like if
they say put a bank robbery in it when it's a love
story or something it's like what and that happens
a lot so I that's one reason why I'm not that big
a fan of writing groups unless it's professional
writers because you can just writers groups that's
why for instance my round table is not a writer's
group because I don't want people giving each
other notes and tearing each other apart and
falling into cat fights and gunfire and whatever
it's like no it's like professional writers
generally will know if something's working or not
they'll just be able to say well okay here's this
another thing that's fun is even in drama
it's good to have comedy humor jokes but not
at the expense of character or plot so if you for
instance if you look at aliens bill paxton is the
one who's given all the jokes basically but and
they all land but that's because that's a part of
his personality it doesn't take away from the fact
they're afraid that there's monsters coming after
him that is never he's never laughing at that
he's nervous and his coping mechanisms make jokes
and so that's and he's great bill paxton's
just great in that movie so but but yeah I mean
a lot of people make mistakes you just have to
be willing to grow and to learn you just have
to be willing to hear people but not be slavish
to them you have to decide that no matter what
you're not going to quit and that doesn't mean
you make crap it means that whatever it takes
you're going to learn what you need to learn
you're going to partner with who you need to
partner with and no matter what the world
does you're going to get to the finish line
that's all it is if you take responsibility and
if you take power and if you decide that the one
person who will be responsible for your success
is you then then then you can't be stopped there's
no way to stop you it's a it's you're on your
path and it's great it's a great thing to wake
up with the knowledge that you're going to create
something wonderful and the world will see it and
you're not a puppet dancing to someone
else's strings you're not you're not
you're not enthralled to anyone other than your
creative vision it's it's it's a great feeling
I think the fact that I mean I came out of the
subway in london the tube before the pandemic
and I was going to a pitch meeting with the bbc
elaine and I and someone on the street said space
command mr sci-fi great that's so great and I
was walking my dogs recently and there was this
russian family we live in a russian neighborhood
russian family walking across the street sort
of laterally these these refrigerator-shaped
people and the man saw me with my dogs he said
mr sci-fi I love your commentaries
particularly star trek discovery thank you
I mean it's wonderful I mean how could you not
love that life it's it's great so yeah so it's
the one thing that makes it all worthwhile is
that when you do it right when you've written
a script and it's gotten made and it's gone out
to the world and what you wanted to say is what
you said and people really valued it it stands
the test of time it lasts decade after decade
maybe hundreds of years and it's that you've done
something worth doing it's it's a great feeling
you're not you're not just kind of punching a
time clock and the lovely part is that you can
work a day job and still do your art or you can
make a living from your art either path is is
honorable and either path gets your gets your work
out to the world and that's what really matters.